je vais
essayez de me livrer à cette mission
impossible qui consiste à essayer de
faire le tour du monde dans lequel nous
vivons et 2 dans lequel nous allons
devoir vivre et de tous les problèmes
que ça soulève en très exactement 1h15
chrono donc comme d'habitude j'y
arriverai pas donc comme d'habitude je
vais essayer de faire des choix et comme
d'habitude je vais faire un très mauvais
choix qui va consister à considérer que
je m'adresse à une population de gens
qui ont des bases scientifiques
donc je vais aller aussi vite que
possible sur toutes les notions
scientifiques et quantitatives que
j'aborderai aujourd'hui voilà ça va
faire un peu gavage des oies mais c'est
probablement le moins a le moins à dire
le moins mauvais arbitrage avec les gens
qui sont dans cette salle dont je
soupçonne au surplus qu'une partie
connaît déjà la chanson par coeur ou en
tout cas une bonne partie des refrains
donc je vais vous parler de ce que
j'appelle la contrainte carbone que je
vais tenter d'expliciter et je vais
essayer de resituer ça dans le cadre du
fonctionnement du monde qui nous entoure
et je vais donc commencer par vous faire
un cours d'économie
mais je vais vous faire un cours
d'économie à ma sauce c'est à dire que
au lieu de vous parler d'économie avec
les notions dont vous entendez
classiquement parler dans le journal je
vais commencer par vous parler
d'économie avec des notions purement
physique au moment où les hommes et les
femmes arrivent sur la planète
on trouve sur cette dernière des stocks
divers et variés des arbres des poissons
en océan des montagnes et c'est que je
vais ranger dans deux catégories une
première catégorie concerne tout ce qui
est non renouvelables à l'échelle d'une
vie humaine par exemple des silex
si vous utilisez des silex y aura une
certaine quantité donc ça pose pas
beaucoup de problèmes mais enfin dès que
vous les utiliser pour faire autre chose
vous utilisez une petite partie d'un
stock qui ne se renouvelle pas c'est
vrai pour tous les minerais métalliques
c'est vrai pour les hydrocarbures aux
échelles de temps dont on parle il faut
quelques dizaines à centaines de
millions d'années pour faire des
hydrocarbures
c'est vrai pour l'océan il faut un
certain temps pour faire un océan
d'ailleurs quelques centaines de
millions d'années
donc si celui qu'on a nous plaît plus on
en a pas d'autres magasins dont vous
avez un certain nombre de stocks non
renouvelables qui sont à notre
disposition
et puis vous avez également des stocks
qui se renouvellent aux échelles de
temps qui nous intéresse
comme par exemple des arbres comme par
exemple des animaux etc
par exemple des poissons les poissons si
on pioche dedans de manière modérée le
stock se renouvelle au fur et à mesure
qu'on utilise donc on a des stocks au
début de notre histoire économique
arrive les hommes qui vont utiliser leur
force de travail ce que dans
l'économique vous avez appris à l'école
on appelle w qui vont utiliser une
partie de ses stocks qu'on appelle de
l'énergie et on va en parler abondamment
derrière et qui vont faire des produits
manufacturés parfaitement futile au
début des arrêts pont d arc des flèches
et c'est essentiel ensuite des machines
à café et puis des tas de trucs
complètement futile aussi des maisons
des voitures des avions et c'est donc le
les hommes prennent leur travail pour
faire ça alors en fait les hommes se
rendent compte que faire ce genre de
truc c'est intéressant et ils vont
stocker une partie de leur production
passée pour augmenter la production
future
et ça c'est un truc qui s'appelle du
capital c'est à dire c'est un c'est un
bien qui sert à augmenter la production
future et dont l'usagé va s'étaler dans
le temps et c'est pas quelque chose qui
se détruit au fur et à mesure qu'on s'en
sert en face à ceux détruits mais à
toute petite vitesse
les hommes trouvent que cela est bel et
bon donc
et puis en plus ils croissent et se
multiplient donc ils vont fournir de
plus en plus de travail consommer de
plus en plus d'énergie la leur au début
puis de l'énergie extracorporelle
ensuite pour faire de plus en plus de
trucs essentiels comme des machines à
café et plus utiles etc
alors dès qu'il commence à taper dans
les stocks non renouvelable pour faire
ça le niveau des stocks baissent alors
comme je le disais tout à l'heure quand
il s'agit du stock de silex c'est pas
très grave
quand il s'agit du stock de bauxite
s'est encore pas monstrueux par contre
il ya un certain nombre de stocks et on
va en parler plus tard qu'ils sont des
stocks dans lesquels la baisse est
aujourd'hui tellement perceptible que ça
handicape à l'évidence la poursuite des
tendances pendant encore longtemps
et puis cette activité frénétique va au
bout d'un moment également commencer à
faire baisser le niveau des stocks qui
se seraient renouvelés si on n'avait pas
piocher trop violemment dedans ça vaut
par exemple pour le stock forestier
le stock foresti en europe a diminué
depuis l'an mille îles et la couverture
forestière est passé de 80 % à 15 %
le stock de poissons a été divisée par
dix dans l'atlantique nord donc un
certain nombre de ressources
renouvelables voient leurs stocks
diminuent et parce que on pioche parce
que le flux sortants et est supérieur
aux flux entrants en faisant cette
activité de plus en plus débridée
on va également avoir un truc qui
s'appelle la pollution et qui est en
fait un vaste fourre tout dans lequel on
range sommairement tout ce qu'ils nous
emmerdent donc tout ce que tout ce qu'on
aime pas c'est de la pollution le bruit
de la congestion les polluants locaux
l'effet de serre les déchets radioactifs
tout ce que vous voulez ça s'appelle la
pollution c'est ce qu'ils nous emmerdent
alors cette pollution en fait a
également des effets sur l'environnement
et si vous en avez trop c'est à dire si
vous perturber trop l'environnement ça
va également vous entamez vostok je vous
parlais tout à l'heure de l'océan unique
que nous avons bas si on le rend trop
acide ou trop pollué ou trop riches en
ceci cela et qu'il devient impropre à
soutenir la vie marine eh bien on a
fichu en l'air notre stock et puis on en
a pas un autre qu'on peut aller chercher
au magasin donc vous voyez ça c'est
l'activité économique des hommes
l'activité économique des hommes est une
activité dans laquelle on transforme des
ressources naturelles pour en faire
autre chose il n'existe pas une activité
économique qui consiste à faire autre
chose que de transformer des ressources
naturelles vos habits sont des
ressources naturelles transformer vos
lunettes sont des ressources naturelles
transformé ça c'est des ressources
naturelles transformer le bâtiment dans
lequel nous sommes sont des ressources
naturelles transformer les voitures en
pagaille sur le parking sont des
ressources naturelles transformé de
risque le parking est une ressource
naturelle transformez vous êtes dans un
univers dans lequel même votre activité
à vous et pas du tout dématérialisé
je reviendrai plus tard et vous vivez
dans un univers dans lequel la totalité
de notre activité économique ça ne
consiste que à traduire avec une
convention une activité physique réel
qui est de la transformation de
ressources naturelles d'accord ça dès
que ça notre activité économique alors
dans cette histoire qu'est ce que les
économistes ont jugé bon de compter ils
ont jugé bon de compter le flux annuel
qui s'appelle le pib donc le pib en gros
c'est la fiche de paye de l'humanité
dans l'activité qui consiste à
transformer des ressources naturelles en
autre chose
c'est ça le pays des 1 pour ceux d'entre
vous qui se souviennent un peu de leur
vieille notion de macroéconomie le pib
c'est la rémunération du travail et des
rentes aux acteurs humains donc il ya
que des acteurs humains dans cette
affaire lorsque vous passez de
ressources dont personne n'a payé le
coût de constitution ou de
reconstitution vers des produits
transformés
quand vous achetez un poisson en étalage
d'un supermarché c'est pas le poisson
vous payez le poisson il est apparu tout
seul dans l'océan sans personne paye
rien ce que vous payez c'est tout le
travail humain qui a permis de
r le bateau qui est allé sur l'océan le
pêcheur qui a conduit le bateau le
camionneur qui a transporté le poisson
la personne enfin exactement lusinchi a
construit le camion les gens qui ont
extrait les hydrocarbures pour permettre
de construire le bateau le camion et
faire avancer tout ce beau monde etc
c'est juste ça que vous payez et vous
payez évidemment des rentes au
propriétaire du moment des ressources
minières que personne absolument
personne n'a pour les quatre personnes
n'avait quoi que ce soit pour les
constituer donc là le pib c'est une
fiche de paye en plus c'est un flux
annuel alors vous voyez qu à partir du
moment où on matérialise juste le flux
annuel
il est évident que plus le flux
augmenter plus les stocks baissent vite
et donc le pib est dans un monde dans
lequel nous approchons des limites
physiques à cette caractéristique très
particulière qui avait soulevé déjà les
travaux de l'équipe meadows dans ce
qu'on appelle classiquement le rapport
du club de rome qui était que tant qu'on
cherche à avoir la croissance
perpétuelle du pib bat plus vite on va
plus vite on va à la faillite et c'est
très exactement ce qu'on est en train de
constater aujourd'hui avec comme je vais
essayer de vous le montrer
l'avenir qui ne sera pas la répétition
du passé pas plus qu'en ce qui concerne
votre propre corps en général l'avenir
de la répétition du passé
c'est pas en observant ce qui se passe
entre 0 et 20 ans chez un être humain
que vous extrapolez raisonnablement ce
qui va se passer entre 50 et 70 et s'est
parfaitement dommage suis bien d'accord
avec vous donc le boxer voilà donc
cesser c'est ça qu'il faut garder en
mémoire c'est qu'on a un indicateur
macroéconomique aujourd'hui qui est
totalement un parfait alors pourquoi
est-ce que ce truc là été mis au point
parce qu'à l'époque où on a commencé
l'économie classique il ya deux il ya à
peu près deux siècles les hommes étaient
comme je vais vous montrer un peu plus
tard considérablement moins nombreux
qu'aujourd'hui le stock était comparé
aux sommes immenses alors si le stock
est infini en première approximation
vous n'allez pas vous emmerdez à passer
des deltas stocks qui sont nuls
donc on a considéré que ce qu'il fallait
prendre en compte c'était le goulet
d'étranglement du moment c'est à dire le
nombre de paires de bras disponibles et
le capital humain disponible et on a
oublié le reste les ordres de grandeur
ont changé d'un facteur 10 d'un facteur
100 d'un facteur 1000 et on a gardé la
même approximation premier roman voilà
si vous faisiez ça dans votre labo vous
feriez vertement vilipendé et là les
économistes font la même chose dans leur
formule et personne ne trouve rien à
redire
enfin si un certain nombre de gens comme
moi mais en gros on continue à utiliser
cet indicateur qui est grossièrement
faux et une mesure absolument pas l'état
de l'humanité ce qu'il aurait fallu
faire dans cette histoire c'est compté
en positif le capital manufacturier où
le stock artificiel créé et comptait
également positif les acquis sociaux
créés à cette occasion donc le capital
social le capital culturel tout ce qu'on
tousse concret à cette occasion de
mettet en positif
sauf qu'il faut pas oublié de compter en
négatif ce qu'on a consommé pour ça et
le jour où la valeur marginale de la
dernière voiture construite est
inférieur à la valeur marginale du
dernier morceau de stock qu'on a
utilisées pour construire la voiture et
faire avancer la voiture fin de la
construction des voitures et on vit
happily ever after avec le nombre de
voitures existants c'est ça qu'il aurait
fallu faire dans un monde dans lequel on
aurait correctement compter l'état
patrimonial de l'humanité et de la
planète sur laquelle elle vit donc le
truc qu'on est en train de faire là de
leconte est juste le pib c'est juste un
machin qui va nous permettre de faire
faillite plus vite je vais vous prendre
un exemple qui va vous parler
imaginons que j'ai hérité ce qui n'est
pas le cas évidemment d'une considérable
fortune de mes parents et que je décide
d'aller jouer au casino
eh bien le pib mesure ce que je dépense
au casino tous les ans voilà donc vous
comprenez assez facilement que plus mon
pib croît et plus vite je vais à marine
donc c'est voilà alors là vous le
comprenez c'est exactement pareil
ce qu'on est en train de faire au niveau
macro exactement pareil alors je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure du club de rome
probablement qu'un certain nombre de
gens maintien qui en a entendu parler du
club de rome dans cette salle vous êtes
très très retrait sur enfin l'âme vous
êtes plus pas représentatif voilà
j'ai posé la même question à mes
étudiants des mines
il ya trois semaines il ya deux mains
qui se sont levés sur 60
voilà donc ça marque une époque alors
qu'est ce qu'ils en avaient qu est ce qu
il avait dit le club de rome il avait
essayé de faire une modélisation
dynamique du comportement de l'humanité
avec un certain nombre de variables
grossière qui était censé représenter ce
qui se passait donc leur variable
grossière s'était par exemple la
population les ressources naturelles
dans lesquelles il avait agrégé le
minerai de mercure et les hydrocarbures
donc on peut dire que c'est un tout
petit peu simpliste mais enfin donc
l'avez vous allez voir que si on prend
juste la contrainte carbone ça marche
assez bien
donc les ressources naturelles la
population la nourriture disponible la
production industrielle disponibles les
niveaux de pollution
on part de 1900 et ma foi de 19 100
jusqu'à la date à laquelle ce rapport a
été écrit il fallait pas être grand
clerc pour constater que toutes avaient
cru tant la population que la production
industrielle que la nourriture etc
on a entamé ses à peine perceptible les
ressources naturelles et on a monté
c'est à peine perceptible le niveau de
pollution est ce que ces braves gens ont
dit en 1972 date du rapport que le monde
allait s'écrouler en 2000 et bien jugez
en par vous même voilà ce qu'ils avaient
dit que enfin voilà la trajectoire qu'il
voyait pour le monde en scénario
business as usual' scénario business as
usual y voyait la population augmente et
la nourriture augmenter la production
industrielle augmenter plus vite que la
population ce qui signifie que la
production par tête aux manques dont peu
de pouvoir d'achat augmente alors david
hicks et les ressources elles ont un peu
baissé mais ce n'est pas encore
dramatique et la pollution à monter mais
ce n'est pas encore dramatique dans
l'épisode rigolo et pour plus tard ce
qu'avait dit en fait cette brave équipe
c'est que quelle que soit l'optimisme
qu'on prenne sur les conditions
initiales du système et le niveau de
ressources etc
le niveau de recyclage la croissance
perpétuelle est un truc qui s'effondre
dans le courant du 21e siècle
voilà c'est ça qu'ils avaient dit ces
braves gens c'est à dire que la
croissance perpétuelle du pib est un
truc qui sera pas perpétuelle du tout et
que ça s'arrête avant que vous soyez
morts pour une bonne partie des gens
dans cette salle est-ce qu'ils ont tort
est ce qu'ils ont raison ça va être tout
l'enjeu de notre discussion
alors je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que
y avait quelque chose qui jouait un rôle
absolument central dans l'économie
qui est l énergie puisque l'économie ne
consiste qu'à transformer des ressources
naturelles ont d'autres choses
ça tombe bien l'énergie intervient dès
qu'on transforme quelque chose en
quelque chose d'autre vous modifiez une
température vous modifiez une vitesse
vous modifiez une forme vous modifiez
une composition chimique vous déplacer
un corps dans un champ de potentiel avec
lequel il interagit vous modifiez une
composition atomique et c'est évidemment
ce qui est plus intéressant pour moi
vous fait interagir accord avec du
rayonnement là dedans à chaque fois vous
avez de l'énergie qui est intervenu et
en fait c'est juste rappeler que
l'énergie est par définition l'unité de
compte de la transformation du monde qui
nous entoure
il n'y a pas de transformation qui
puisse prendre place sans que de
l'énergie interviennent dans cette
affaire donc dire que les gens en
consomment de plus en plus d'énergie ça
n'est rien d'autre que de dire que
chaque individu pris isolément à une
aptitude à transformer son environnement
qui va croissant c'est exactement la
même chose
c'est exactement la même chose alors une
fois que je vous ai dit ça vous
comprenez que il n'existe pas d'énergie
propre ou sale dans l'absolu puisque
c'est juste une affaire de doses si
grâce à la fusion on mettait au point
l'énergie propre soi-disant et ses
infinies et gratuite et bien j'aurai la
possibilité de ratisser la totalité des
poissons de l'océan en un seul coup de
filet j'aurai la possibilité d'arracher
une montagne en un seul clic sur un
bouton et c est ce que c'est un monde
dans lequel on a envie de vivre
ben on peut se poser la question comme
l'énergie n'est est révélé à l'occasion
d'une transformation et bien chaque
transformation a ses avantages et ses
inconvénients
mais il n'existe pas de transformation
qui soit neutre puisque par définition
c'est une transformation
donc chaque transformation a ses
avantages et ses inconvénients chaque
source d'énergie présente ses avantages
et ses inconvénients
on va voir que en ce qui concerne un
certain nombre de sources
on a des contraintes qui sont exogènes
c'est à dire qu'on peut trépigner
parterre crier pouvoir d'achat etc
on a des contraintes exogènes il va
falloir qu'on fasse avec et en gros
disserter sur l'avenir énergétique c'est
faire de l'optimisation sous contrainte
c'est à dire voir quels sont les degrés
de liberté qui reste accessible et ceux
qui deviennent interdits dans le monde
que nous allons connaître à l'avenir
et bien évidemment vous allez voir que
dans cette histoire il
question que de chiffres et donc je vais
vous assommer avec des chiffres alors le
premier chiffre avec lequel je vais vous
assommer c'est celui d'arc secteu mans à
première batterie de chiffres
ce graphique représente l'évolution de
la consommation d'énergie par personne à
la surface de la planète donc c'est une
moyenne mondiale depuis 1880 alors là
dedans vous n'avez pas le bois c'est la
seule énergie qui soit pas représentée
là dessus et qui on va dire ajouterait à
peu près ça et c'est à peu près constant
depuis depuis cette époque alors le
premier constat que vous pouvez faire
c'est que depuis un siècle la
consommation de charbon par individu en
moyenne planétaire et constante donc le
charbon n'a absolument pas disparu de
nos misérables vies est l'une des
raisons à cela c'est que le charbon
représente à peu près 40% de la
production d'électricité mondiale
le charbon est avant tout une énergie
des pays riches les plus gros
consommateurs de charbon par tête de
pipe c'est les américains les
australiens
c'est pas du tout les chinois le charbon
c'est 50% d'électricité américaine c'est
50% d'électricité allemande c'est 30%
des lectrices en plus que ça mais ça va
être 50 aussi d'électricité danoise
c'est un tiers de l'électricité
européenne at large
c'est un truc qui est absolument
centrale dans le système électrique des
pays développés absolument centrale
le pétrole est venue se rajouter
là-dessus le gaz est venue se rajouter
là-dessus et c'est vous voyez que à
l'échelle des temps historiques
il n'existe pas une forme d'énergie
quand et cannibalisé une autre ou alors
pas suffisamment pour que ça se voit sur
ce graphique
en gros c'est plutôt une superposition
des croissances à laquelle on a eu droit
vous voyez également que les trente
glorieuses que chacun de nos dirigeants
aimeraient bien reproduire chaque fois
qu'ils étaient lus ont été marqués par
une très forte hausse de la croissance
d'énergie par personne et vous m'avez
déjà compris à cette heure ci on va y
revenir un certain nombre de fois la
question est bien évidemment de savoir
si on peut avoir une croissance
économique forte sans avoir une
croissance énergétique forte et comme ça
ça ça et même le nucléaire ça tape dans
des stocks fini la probabilité pour
qu'on ait une croissance perpétuelle de
l'approvisionnement de ce truc là par
personne avec une démographie qu'une
humanité dans la population est stable
et rigoureusement nul donc ça ça pose la
question de savoir
comment tout ça va se comporter à
l'avenir vous voyez que actuellement on
a à peu près 20 milles kilowatts heure
par personne et par an en moyenne
planétaire
si vous vous serviez de vos bras et de
vos jambes pour avoir la même chose
exactement si vous aviez des esclaves
qui se servaient de leur bras et de
leurs jambes pour avoir la même chose il
faudrait que chacun d'entre vous on est
alors en france on est aux alentours de
300 là vous êtes plutôt aux alentours de
100 en france on est à 50 milles
kilowatts heure par personne et par an
or ce qui est contenu dans les
importations
donc vous voyez qu'on a acquis à travers
la consommation d'énergie une puissance
de feu son mauvais jeu de mots
absolument considérable sans précédent
dans l'histoire de l'humanité et tous
les gens qui se mettent en grève en
disant qu'ils en ont pas assez ne se
rendent pas compte ne se rendent pas
compte que ils ont déjà en france
l'équivalent de 100 à 150 domestique à
leur disposition 24 heures sur 24 et 365
jours par an à travers leur consommation
d'énergie et les raisons de la
satisfaction sont allés chercher
ailleurs je vous renvoie à tocqueville
qui avait expliqué qu'en démocratie on
serait perpétuellement entre un conte
shawn est à mon avis la raison est
beaucoup plus liée à ça plutôt qu'au
niveau de consommation dans l'absolu il
faut rajouter à cinq le nombre de
consommateurs a augmenté un poil vous
avez ici l'évolution de la démographie
sur notre planète
depuis que l'homme s'est sédentarisé
donc ici début de l'agriculture au
moment alors vous me pardonnerez ce
parisianisme de mauvais aloi au moment
où l'humanité se sédentarisent on a la
moitié de la population francilienne qui
est répartie sur la terre entière donc
la population planétaire c'est la moitié
de la population francilienne actuelle
au moment où la révolution industrielle
ou agricole sa lindsay n'était pas
extrêmement précis à cette époque là
démarre on est à peu près un demi
milliard et vous voyez quand huit
générations en huit générations
on a eu le type lié sa part 10 et là on
a une évolution qui est plus près de
l'hyperbole que l'exponentielle s'étaler
extrêmement vite extrêmement vite et
s'étaler extrêmement vite au moment où
on a commencé à utiliser l'énergie
abondante ce qui fait qu'un certain
nombre de gens aujourd'hui se pose la
question de savoir si une énergie
beaucoup plus contingenté permettra de
continuer à avoir quelques milliards
d'hommes sur terre sans que tout ça ne
dégénère en sombre pugilat
et c'est une vraie question si je
reviens à ma définition de l'énergie qui
est que c'est la pression de l'homme sur
l'environnement voilà comment au premier
rang bras évoluer la pression notre
espèce sur l'environnement elle évolue
comme la démographie elle évolue comme
la quantité d'énergie consommée par
personne donc je compose les deux pour
avoir quelque chose qui ressemble peu ou
à l'évolution de la pression de l'espèce
sur l'environnement et vous voyez là de
manière évidente que les débats qu'on
peut avoir aujourd'hui ne sont pas des
débats qui sont liées au fait qu'on a
des processus qui ont qualitativement
changé ce sont des débats qui sont liées
au fait que les ordres de grandeur en
jeu ont considérablement changé
c'est juste un problème d'ordre de
grandeur cette affaire là alors nos
esclaves virtuel aujourd'hui où est ce
qu'ils sont et bien les voici
vous avez tous entre 20 et 40 paires de
bras qui turbinent en permanence pour
vous dans l'agriculture c'est ce qui a
permis de passer la population active de
70% de paysans à 2% et la productivité
d'un paysan ayant été multipliés par
deux sens au passage ça tout ça c'est
grâce à l'énergie donc aujourd'hui parce
que si vous aviez besoin de faire
pousser des patates huit heures par jour
ça serait un peu difficile de faire des
recherches à côté ensuite nous avons
tous entre 30 et 60 esclaves à notre
disposition en permanence qui s'appelle
des transports
j'ai vu qu'il y avait un certain nombre
de voitures garées sur le parking ici et
bien la puissance développée par un
moteur de voiture c'est autant de
chevaux attelés que vous avez deux
chevaux sur la documentation commerciale
de votre voiture donc si vous avez une
c1 ou une c2 à 50 chevaux et bien vous
enlevez le moteur vous remplacer sa part
50 chevaux devant la carrosserie c'est
la même puissance développée c'est juste
pas le même prix donc aujourd'hui pour
15% votre budget c'est à dire une somme
ridiculement faible vous avez les moyens
de rouler dans un carrosse avec 50 à 100
chevaux attelés devant c'est à dire un
truc absolument personne je dis bien
absolument personne ne pouvait se payer
il ya deux siècles pas une personne sur
terre navets un carrosse avec 50 chevaux
devant il ya deux siècles pas une
et aujourd'hui c'est à la portée de 600
ou 800 millions d'individus
vous avez nous avons tous quelques
dizaines d'esclaves mécanique qui
turbinent en permanence dans les usines
pour noé qui font vos vêtements les
chaises sur lesquelles vous êtes assis
l'ordinateur dont je suis en train de me
servir la table sur lequel il est posé
les gobelets en plastique qui étaient à
l'entrée merci de café etc etc tout ça
c'est quelques dizaines en gros entre 50
et 100 ça dépend de la manière de conter
d'esclaves qui turbinent en permanence
pour nous en permanence
l'énergie fossile a vraisemblablement
joué un rôle significatif dans la
disparition d' esclavage sur terre c'est
assez vraisemblable et évidemment sans
faire de pronostic
ça pose la question de savoir ce qui va
se passer quand il va commencer à y
avoir de la contingence sur cette
énergie
ça c'est ce qui a remplacé les vaches ça
s'appelle le chauffage central
après vous avez quelques dizaines
d'esclaves à votre disposition à travers
les usages spécifiques de l'électricité
c'est à dire tout ce qui sert à monter
et descendre des charges tout ce qui
sert à pomper quelque chose tout ce qui
est c'est que ça vous garde les aliments
au froid ça vous les cuisines
éventuellement si vous avez un micro
ondes à ça vous lave le linge ça vous
lave la vaisselle etc
tout ça c'est des domestiques liés à la
consommation d'énergie et nous en avons
tous quelques dizaines à notre
disposition en permanence 24h sur 24
voilà donc aujourd'hui alors qu'on pense
vivre comme des miséreux avec une perte
de pouvoir d'achat et cetera nous ayons
comme des nababs comme des nababs un
français on fera hibernatus là c'est à
dire qu'un français d'il ya deux siècles
qui arriverait dans le monde dans lequel
nous vivons et qui nous verrait
ronchonner parce qu'on en a pas assez se
demanderaient sur quelle planète il est
arrivé bon parce qu'il ya deux siècles
les gens vivaient dans une pièce c'était
toute la population était paysanne pour
l'essentiel donc les gens vivaient dans
une pièce pas chauffer sans éducation
pour les gosses sans vacances les gens
vous allez voir un peu plus tard faisait
en moyenne 2 km à pied par jour c'était
ça leur déplacement ils avaient leur
rayon d'action toute leur vie durant
c'était en général quelques kilomètres
et pas plus
il n'y avait pas la musique y avait à
faire voir c'est il faut se rendre
compte
là où on en est arrivé aujourd'hui alors
l'une des raisons pour laquelle est là
je vais revenir à l'économie
ça a pu se passer cette affaire c'est
que contrairement à une idée couramment
répandue l'énergie et d'une manière
générale
n'importe quels biens manufacturés ne
vaut pas de plus en plus cher mais de
moins en moins chers en prix réel
n'importe quoi vous prenez absolument
n'importe quoi et je vais vous montrer
quelques exemples ici vous avez quelque
chose qui va me permettre de démarrer
mon raisonnement
ans qui est le prix déflatés du pétrole
depuis qu'on a commencé l'exploitation
industrielle du pétrole
alors vous voyez que au début ça fait
quelques zigzags et puis en 1881 environ
le prix se stabilise aux alentours de 20
dollars le baril
et même un peu plus bas pendant un
siècle c'est à dire que pendant un
siècle où on a fait nos villes fait nos
infrastructures fait nos métiers fait
nos industries fai la restructuration
agricoles etc
le pétrole reste à un prix constant
pendant que le pouvoir d'achat par
personne en données réels augmentent
comme ça ça c'est depuis ce marché le
prix de marché
non le prix à la production il ya
beaucoup moins variés que ça donc vous
êtes vous avez le prix qui restent à peu
près constant pendant que le pouvoir
d'achat en dollar constant également du
consommateur lui il augmente d'un
facteur on va dire à peu près 20 depuis
1860 et si vous prenez l'évolution se
fait aux états unis mais c'est très
représentatif des pays occidentaux si
vous prenez l'évolution depuis le début
du siècle on est en gros un facteur 10
ça veut dire quoi cette histoire ça veut
dire que le temps qu'il faut travailler
pour se payer un kilowatt heure de
n'importe quoi a été en gros divisé par
10 en l'espace d'un siècle et comme dans
le même laps de temps les gens de la
corporation ont fait un boulot efficace
c'est à dire que l'efficacité
énergétique a été multipliée en groupe
par un facteur 2 à 3 ça veut dire que le
prix réel de mon esclave énergétique
dont je parlais tout à l'heure a été
divisé par 30 sur le courant du 20e
siècle
n'allez pas chercher ailleurs
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat vous
l'avez l'on n'allait pas la chercher
ailleurs
elle est là on a acquis la possibilité
de remuer 30 fois plus de matière en un
siècle que ce qu'on faisait en 1902
logements plus grands logements moins
chers voiture plus grosse voiture plus
accessible etc etc et vous prenez
absolument n'importe quel produit
manufacturé son prix réel s'est cassé la
gueule
son prix réel s'est cassé la gueule sur
le courant du dernier siècle n'importe
lequel
alors quelques illustrations ici vous
avez la dépense énergétique par passager
kilomètre pour faire selon mode de
transport pardon donc c'est la quantité
d'énergie qu'il faut consommer cd
grammes équivalent pétrole suis désolé
c'est pas d'un système international
pour faire un kilomètre selon le mode de
transport eh bien vous constatez que le
sens de l'histoire c'est d'aller vers la
droite
c'est à dire qu'avec la baisse du prix
réel de l'énergie se sont démocratisés
au fil du temps d'abord la bicyclette
puis le train puis l'autobus
puis la voiture et l'avion ccc usage là
ce sont d or à chaque fois que vous
faites un saut dans la liste que je
viens de vous énumérer
eh bien vous augmenter la quantité
d'énergie qu'il faut utiliser pour qu'un
passager parcours 1 km il est assez
vraisemblable que dans un monde contre
un sur l'énergie ont fait une partie du
chemin inverse
autres manifestations liées à la baisse
du prix réel de l'énergie l'augmentation
du parc de voitures que vous avez ici
voyez entre l'année de ma naissance en
gros est aujourd'hui est bien le parc de
voitures a été multiplié par un facteur
4 par cancale a été multiplié par un
facteur 4
donc c'est pas 5% c'est un facteur 4 ici
vous avez quelque chose que moi je
trouve assez intéressant même si c'est
un peu difficile à dire c'est en échelle
logarithmique 1 c'est le nombre de
kilomètres fait en moyenne par personne
et par jour selon le mode de transport
en france depuis 18 ans alors le truc
qui est la référence et la marche que
vous avez en blanc a envoyé en 1800 une
personne fait en moyenne tous modes
confondus
ça c'est le violet 3 km par personne et
par jour et en fait c'est
essentiellement de la marche à pied il
faut descendre trois ordres de grandeur
en dessous pour trouver le cheval qui
est réservé à une micro élite qui est
capable de se déplacer en carriole donc
le trajet moyen domicile travail du
paysan de l'époque puisque à l'époque
tout le monde était paysan vous allez
voir taylor 70% des gens étaient paysans
et puis les la moitié des gens restants
étaient employées de maison donc c'est
pareil lors de trajets domicile-travail
était pas très long et bien trois
kilomètres par personne et par jour à
pied c'était ça le déplacement moyen des
gens il faut attendre ici là 1952 pour
que le déplacement moyen par personne et
par jour en voiture dépasse de manière
significative la quantité de kilomètres
fait par personne et par jour en papier
voilà il ya un certain nombre de gens
dans cette salle qui à mon avis était
déjà vivant en 1952
donc il était déjà vivant à l'époque où
la voiture a supplanté la marche à pied
comme mode de transports permettant de
faire le plus de kilomètres en moyenne
par personne et par jour
c'est très très récent très très récents
les plus jeunes dans cette salle sont
nés dans un monde dans lequel on fait ça
comme on respire
c'est très récent et vous allez voir
après que la probabilité que ça dure
très longtemps est une vraie question
ici voici encore une autre illustration
de l'énergie abondante et à bas prix
dont vous bénéficiez dans ses locaux
excentré et accessible uniquement en
voiture c'est la quantité d'énergie et
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
qui sont liées au confort thermique et
aux déplacements quotidiens pour un
appartement mais je peux traduire ça
pour des locaux d'activité c'est
exactement pareil hein pour un
appartement en fonction de sa
localisation dans l'île de france mais
ça marche quelle que soit la ville
comprend eh bien vous voyez que plus
vous allez vers la banlieue lointaine et
plus les émissions liées au chauffage
est liée au dés à la mobilité
quotidienne sont importantes pour le
chauffage c'est normal vous avez plus en
plus d'habitat individuel donc une des
surfaces en contact avec l'extérieur qui
en proportion augmente et en ce qui
concerne les déplacements quotidiens
vous êtes dans des tissus de plus en
plus lâche
donc si vous voulez conserver la
fonction des changes qui l'a fonctions
urbaines
donc les gens se déplacent et bien vous
avez de plus en plus d'énergie qui est
nécessaire pour assurer cette fonction
des changes
et c'est pas un hasard si les villes
américaines qui se sont constitués à un
moment où l'énergie était déjà abondante
et à bas prix se sont fait avec ce genre
de tissu urbain et non pas ce genre de
tissu urbain c'est parce que comme
l'énergie valait déjà pas grand chose
on a fait un truc qui était adaptée à
une énergie peu cher évidemment quand
l'énergie va devenir cher ça pose la
question de savoir ce que deviennent les
charges de fonctionnement de ce truc là
et ça pose une question qui à mon avis
est encore plus envers dante qui est de
savoir comment vont évoluer les bassins
d'emploi parce que ma théorie c'est que
ça va se contracter
donc les gens qui sont en deuxième
couronne non seulement ils auront des
charges plus élevées mais ils ont au
moins deux jobs et du coup les
engagements de toutes les bandes qui
l'auront fait des crédits immobiliers
iront pas très bien ici vous avez autre
chose
ce qu'on est en train de vivre en ce
moment mais j'y reviendrai au moment de
la discussion probablement est à mon
avis assez représentatif de ce qui nous
attend mais pour mme ans la petite
échelle dans un monde dans lequel on ne
prend pas ce genre de contraintes à bras
le corps un explosion du prix de
l'énergie récession économique
et comme le métier des banques c'est
prendre des paris sur l'avenir le pari
ne se matérialise pas eh ben on se casse
la gueule si on pense que les banques
sont la cause du problème actuel on se
trompe la cause du problème actuel c'est
l'augmentation de l'endettement c'est à
dire si leur comportement passé mais
aussi l'augmentation très forte du prix
de l'énergie qu'on vient de
combien de vivre je reviens mais vous
aurez un petit graphique ap répondre là
dessus donc je reviens à cette affaire
là ici vous avez quelque chose qui bat
en brèche une autre idée couramment
reçues qui est que plus vous augmentez
la part des services dans l'emploi et
plus votre société et dématérialisés et
bien comme aurait dit un certain un
personnage célèbre de que nos monts et
c'est pas du tout ici vous voyez que
quand on augmente la part des services
dans l'emploi on a tendance plutôt à
augmenter les émissions de co2 par
personne est en tout cas même si cette
corrélation n'est pas parfaite il ya une
chose de sûre c'est que vous avez pas
celle là c'est pareil avec l'énergie
leur adresser au delà je vous montre
l'énergie et je vous montre l'énergie
sur un ensemble de pays beaucoup plus
vaste puisque vous avez à peu près tous
les pays du monde ici vous voyez que si
on essaye de faire une corrélation elle
est à la hausse est en tout cas une
chose est sûre c'est qu'elle n'est pas à
la baisse c'est absolument certain que
vous avez pas une corrélation comme ça
dans ce nuage de points donc l'idée
qu'il suffit d'augmenter la part de
l'emploi dans les services pour avoir
pour régler notre problème de co2 et
d'énergie malheureusement c'est
complètement faux toutes choses égales
par ailleurs
alors la raison à cela à mon avis elle
est tout bêtement liés à ce graphique
ici vous avez l'évolution depuis deux
siècles de la part de l'emploi dans
chaque secteur agriculture industrie et
services la part des agriculteurs
s'étaient deux tiers en 1800 c'est ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure le
français ordinaires en 1807 un paysan et
le français des services ordinaires
donc le tertiaire à l'époque c'était
pour une personne sur deux employées de
maison
c'était ça la moitié des services qu'est
ce qui s'est passé
l'énergie abondante et à bas prix a
permis de remplacer les paysans pour en
faire des ouvriers puis a permis de
remplacer les ouvriers pour en faire des
cols blancs est ce que cette affaire-là
vous laisse penser une seule seconde que
la tertiarisation est un truc qui est
indépendant de l'utilisation de
l'énergie
non on a juste remplacé les fonctions
productives par des machines qui
consomment de l'énergie etc machine
consomme pas mal d'énergie puisque vous
avez aujourd'hui beaucoup plus de biens
manufacturés à votre disposition que les
gens n'avaient en 1800 donc tout le
monde confond un ratio sur juste un truc
qu'on mesure qui est la part de l'emploi
dans les services avec la pression
globale de l'homme sur son environnement
qui a considérablement augmenté quel que
soit l'indicateur que vous
renié depuis cette époque tout
simplement parce que les machines ne
sont pas dans l'emploi si on mettait le
nombre de machines qui fonctionnent dans
la population active
on aurait un diagramme tout à fait
différent car il faut que je fasse le
calcul ça c'est assez rigolo est par
ailleurs un autre truc qu'on oublie
souvent c'est qu'un pourcentage c'est
pas une valeur absolue alors je voulais
montrer tout à l'heure pour le charbon
1 c'est pas parce que le pourcentage du
charbon baisse qui ont valeur absolue la
part du charbon a fallu la quantité de
charbon consommé baisse l'augmentent et
c'est exactement pareil ici c'est pas
parce qu'en pourcentage les emplois
industriels ont baissé sur les dizaines
d'années qui viennent de s'écouler qu'en
valeur absolue on a moins d'emplois
industriels aujourd'hui que à une époque
ancienne
là on avait deux millions d'emplois
industriels là on en a 6 millions
pourtant la part dans l'emploi est à peu
près la même
donc en valeur absolue et si vous
regardez un indicateur qui pourrait être
par exemple le nombre d'ouvriers par
hectares de sols en france et bien cet
indicateur a triplé et il n'est pas du
tout descendu donc le choix de
l'indicateur est évidemment déterminant
dans la conclusion continent l'énergie
abondante et à bas prix a aussi permis
de faire ça là vous êtes avant guerre
vous avez encore à peu près un tiers de
la population active qui est paysanne
ici vous êtes aujourd'hui vous avez 2%
de la population active qui est paysanne
est évidemment à due concurrence un tas
d'emplois qui servait les paysans sont
partis des campagnes également vous
voyez que l'énergie abondante et à bas
prix à structurer un urbanisme bien
particulier en vie dans les campagnes et
en faisant des grandes mégapoles et
allez ça c'est viable parce que vous
pouvez avoir des très grands bassins
d'emploi quand l'énergie vaut cher les
gens peuvent faire de grandes distances
en voiture c'est pas un problème et vous
pouvez mettre beaucoup de gens dans les
activités tertiaires dans les villes
pour gérer une production faite par des
machines
parce que c'est ça les activités
tertiaires sait gérer une production
faite par des machines y compris vous
les moyens d'observation vous utilisez
ces des machines
donc on peut gérer des machines en
mettant tout le monde en ville dans un
monde dans lequel l'énergie ne vaut rien
donc c'est normal que vous ayez de la
concentration urbaine et c'est normal
que vous ayez des mégapoles est allé
quand l'énergie commenceront à valoir
quelque chose tout ce modèle
d'aménagement du territoire sera remis
en question et comme l'aménagement du
territoire c'est pas un truc qui se fait
en une semaine
il est évident qu'il faut
considérablement anticiper ce genre
d'évolution si on veut pas avoir affaire
à des drames sociaux ce qui sera la
manière dont ça se règlera sinon ça a
également joué sur notre alimentation
cette affaire-là alors là aussi je vais
me permettre d'expliquer que
contrairement à ce que
d'aucuns l'alimentation n'a jamais coûté
aussi peu cher qu'aujourd'hui pour
jamais autant de protéines animales
vous avez ici des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre d'un certain nombre pour
un certain nombre d'aliments pour la
production d'un kilo d'un certain nombre
d'aliments et vous voyez que en gros là
c'est pareil le sens de l'histoire
c'était nous entraîner vers la droite
grâce à l'augmentation du contenu en
hydrocarbures de la nourriture et ses
émissions violette là c'est également
liées à l'énergie puisque c'est les
émissions d'épandage des engrais de
synthèse
lesquels sont faits avec du gaz naturel
donc ça c'est les émissions de
fabrication des engrais que vous avez en
bleu les émissions d'épandage des
engrais sont là et en jaune ce que vous
avez c'est la méthanisation des
ruminants où les émissions de méthane
des déjections
alors vous voyez que au début les gens
mangeaient des produits végétaux puis se
sont mis à manger des oeufs puis sont
faits a mis à faire de la valorisation
de déchets c'est à dire à manger les
poules puis ils sont mis à manger du
poulet puisse des poules avec des ailes
en jeu précise
puis ils sont mis à manger des produits
laitiers puis sont mis à manger les
bêtes qui donnait les produits laitiers
elle même donc le sens de l'histoire
c'est de nous entraîner vers des
aliments qui sont de plus en plus riches
en gaz à effet de serre et qui
nécessitent de plus en plus d'énergie
pour être produits dans un kilo de
crevettes ou un kilo de thon tropical
vous avez entre 1 et 3 litres
d'hydrocarbures qui sont inclus dans la
pêche ou la production de ces trucs là
dans un kilo de boeuf vous avez un litre
d'hydrocarbures qui sont inclus à
travers l'agriculture céréalière qu'il a
fallu faire en amont progrès les
bestiaux il faut savoir que la moitié
des céréales cultivées dans ce pays vont
nourrir du bétail 1 c'est pas fait pour
être mangés directement donc c'est la
mécanisation et l'énergie abondante qui
a permis de faire ce genre de choses et
qui a permis cette évolution là c'est à
dire de multiplier par cinq la quand la
quantité de viande dans la ration
quotidienne avec un prix qui lui s'est
cassé la gueule
alors vous voyez ici l'évolution de la
part de l'alimentation dans le budget
des ménages aux états unis mais en
france exactement pareil depuis 1930 et
vous voyez que cette part de
l'alimentation elle est passée en gros
d'un quart du budget à 10%
mais en fait c'est aller encore plus
vite que ça parce que en 1930 les
ménages dans ce qu'ils achètent achète
80 % de produits bruts des patates des
carottes des choux
the etc en 2006 c'est 20 % les produits
bruts dans ce qu'ils achètent dans la
restauration hors domicile quand vous
allez chez mcdo ce que les produits
bruts c'est 20% du ticket de caisse
et quand vous allez au supermarché dès
que vous achetez des biscuits des plats
préparés des yaourts des soucis d cela
c'est à dire des produits de l'industrie
agroalimentaire c'est pareil les
produits bruts c'est à peu près 20% de
ce que vous allez payer
et comme l'agroalimentaire c'est 80 %
des dépenses d'alimentation des ménages
en gros aujourd'hui en première
approximation s'est passé à 20% du total
ce qui veut dire que le prix réel des
aliments a été divisée par dix ça c'est
encore l'énergie abondante et à bas prix
donc attendez-vous à payer la bouffe
plus cher c'est normal absolument rien
d'étonnant là dedans pour des raisons
physiques
voilà ce que je suis en train de vous
expliquer depuis une demi heure c'est
que on a tout bâti tout notre équilibre
socio économique actuelle sur un truc
d'une simplicité biblique trouver des
trucs qui brûle sous terre les faire
brûler grâce à ça à voir les moteurs et
la chimie et les moteurs et la chimie
nous ont amené la totalité de ce qui
vous entoure
tout autour de vous et moteurs et chimie
et ça évidemment ça a également amené le
système socio économique dans lequel
nous vivons
l'urbanisme la structure des métiers la
retraite à 60 ans enfin elle est un peu
en dessous maintenant mais ça va
remonter ça c'est évident les études
longues qui vont se raccourcir le
divorce qui va diminuer après le divorce
va diminuer parce que quand les gens
divorcent les ex-conjoints augmentent
leur consommation d'énergie de 60 %
instantanément il faut construire deux
fois plus de logements
il faut les chauffer il faut multiplier
par deux tous les objets de la vie
courante le lit la baignoire la boe
bouilloires électriques etc
donc il faut consommer regarder ou un
divorce dans les pays qui consomme plein
d'énergie dans ces pays là que mon
divorce dans les autres pays on y verse
pas donc dans un monde contre un en
énergie vous allez avoir une contrainte
sur le pouvoir d'achat et ça va
contraindre le divorce
voilà donc la totalité du monde dans
lequel nous vivons est assis sur un truc
qui est tout bête et qui s'appelle les
combustibles fossiles
alors tout ça c'est parfait dans un
monde infini dans le monde fini ça pose
de questions
la première c'est combien de temps
est-ce que je peux creusé à vitesse
accélérée sous le sol pour faire sortir
en quantité croissante ces fichus
combustibles fossiles et une deuxième
question qui et combien de temps est-ce
que je peux mettre le sous produit de
cette combustion dans l'atmosphère
avant que la modification des échanges
énergétiques entre la surface et
l'espace que ça induit ne me perturbent
le climat d'une manière telle que je
trouverai l'expérience extrêmement
saumâtre alors je vais traiter beaucoup
plus la première que la deuxième
question parce que vu l'endroit où je
suis je considère que la deuxième
question vous en savez déjà pas mal
si c'est faux tant pis pour vous il faut
faire un choix je vais reprendre ce que
je vous disais tout à l'heure sur
l'énergie et voilà comment a évolué la
quantité d'énergie totale consommée par
l'humanité hors bois depuis un siècle et
demi donc c'est consommation par
personne x nombre de personnes tout à
l'heure je vous avais juste montrer
consommation par personne
alors vous voyez encore une fois les
augmentations qui ont été tellement
tellement vite en ce qui concerne la
quantité d'énergie consommée entre la
génération de mes parents et la
génération des enfants est quasiment un
facteur 10 sur la quantité d'énergie qui
a été consommée par les hommes c'est
absolument monstrueux et vous voyez que
80% de cette énergie est faite de stock
alors il fallait tirer de stock or cette
énergie là est ce qu'on appelle énergie
primaire c'est celle qu'on trouve dans
la nature
et là je suis tout petit peu de manque
nature dans la nature vous ne trouvez
que ça vous trouvez du charbon où
trouver du pétrole
vous trouvez du gaz vous trouvez des
noyaux qui veulent bien se casser en
deux et vous trouvez ce qu'on appelle
des énergies renouvelables donc la
combustion du bois
les lots qui tombe et c'est le vent qui
souffle vous mettez assez peu de vent
qui souffle dans votre voiture et vous
utilisez assez peu de charbon brut pour
faire tourner une cafetière électrique
vous ce que vous allez utiliser c'est ce
qu'on appelle d énergie finale
c'est-à-dire des transformations de ces
combustibles pour avoir des trucs qui
rentre dans les machines dont nous nous
servons alors les machines dont nous
nous servons c'est des chaudières des
voitures des cafetières électriques et
c'est donc là on va on va trouver pour
ceux qui en utilisent encore du charbon
sous une forme utilisable par des poêles
on va trouver les carburants raffinés
fioul
super carburant etc diesel on va trouver
du gaz purifier parce que là quand ça
sort il est apte ruch dedans dont vous
n'avez pas envie dans les réseaux de
transports par exemple le gaz de la mer
du nord il peut contenir jusqu'à 10 % de
co2 quand il sort et vous n'avez pas
envie de mettre le co2 dans les tuyaux
vous allez trouver de l'électricité qui
n'existe pas dans la nature sauf à
capter les orages alors je vous signale
qu'il ya une blague je suis désolé pour
nos amis américains mais il ya une
blague que je on entend souvent qui est
que quand vous faites un sondage aux
états unis et que vous demandez aux gens
d'où viennent d'où vient l'électricité
faudra le faire en france d'où vient
l'électricité la moitié des gens vous
disent du mur avant le mur il ya eu ça
avant lui réussit alors à fait cette
énergie finale vous ne l'utilisez pas
juste pour le plaisir de voir un litre
d'essence brûlé vous allez en tirer ce
qu'on appelle de l'énergie utile
c'est-à-dire du mouvement quand vous
mettez un litre d'essence dans une
voiture qui vous intéresse vraiment
c'est le mouvement
quand vous mettez un litre d'essence
dans un bolide de fioul dans une
chaudière qui vous intéresse vraiment
c'est l'élévation de température dans
une pièce donc en gros ce qui va vous
intéresser c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'énergie utile et à chaque fois que
vous franchissez une étape de primaire à
finale et deux finales à utile vous
allez perdre en route une partie de
l'énergie
l'essentiel de l'énergie perdue de
primaire à finale ll est en faisant ça
parce que monsieur carnot a dit que
quand vous commencez par faire de la
chaleur pour faire du mouvement vous
allez en perdre un sacré paquet au
passage
or 85 % d'électricité mondiale est fait
en commençant par faire bouillir de
l'eau qu'ils s'agissent des centrales à
charbon et à gaz à fuel ou nucléaire
tout ça c'est faire bouillir de l'eau
d'une manière différente mais c'est
faire bouillir de l'eau et donc à
l'arrivée vous allez perdre n'importe
quoi entre 45 dans les excellents cas de
figure et 80% dans les mauvais de la
chaleur initial et le nucléaire n'a pas
l'apanage des mauvais rendements les
centrales à charbon dans le monde ont un
rendement qui à peu près celui des
centrales nucléaires donc c'est pas
c'est pas juste c'est monsieur carnot
quand vous allez passer de finale à
utile
vous allez aussi avoir des pertes alors
là ils peuvent être considérables si je
prends vous et votre organisme qui même
très bien nourris va rapidement va
rarement pardon dépassé les 100 kg si je
considère que je vous met dans une
voiture d'une tonne et demie
avancez l'énergie vraiment utile c'est
celle qui déplace votre corps l'énergie
finale que vous allez utiliser c'est un
peu plus que ça donc en passant de
l'énergie finale à utile c'est-à-dire le
service que ça rend vous pouvez avoir
des niveaux de pertes extrêmement
important alors il est bien il est il
est important de bien savoir de quel
type d'énergie on parle parce que vous
dans la grande presse vous voyez tout
mélanger tout le reste est évidemment on
n'en tire pas les mêmes conclusions
alors je reprends mon histoire en ce qui
concerne l'énergie primaire voilà à quoi
ça ressemble aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui un tiers de l'énergie
primaire consommée par la planète c'est
du pétrole 25% du charbon 20% du gaz
et vous savez lire le reste ce qui veut
dire que 80% de cette énergie primaire
elle est faite de combustibles fossiles
donc je vous ai dit c'est des résidus de
vie ancienne qui sont apparus il ya
quelques centaines de millions d'années
où quelques dizaines de millions
d'années on a un stock qui est donnée
une fois pour toute et par ailleurs
c'est plein de carbone puisque c'est de
la vie ancienne donc vous le brûler ça
fait du co2 est absolument pas moyen d'y
échapper
à partir de ça on va faire de l'énergie
finale et l'électricité dans cette
énergie finale est fait en utilisant des
énergies primaires donc l'électricité
n'est pas une énergie propre
l'électricité est une énergie qui est
une aussi bonne idée que la manière de
la faire tu d'aussi bonnes idées que la
manière de la faire
il n'existe pas d'électricité propre
bullshit c'est pas vrai il n'existe pas
d'hydrogène propre bullshit
c'est pas vrai il existe un hydrogène
qui est une aussi bonne idée que la
manière de le faire c'est une énergie
finale
vous n'avez pas de réservoir d'hydrogène
dans la nature alors là un petit
souvenir de maths que vous avez sûrement
tous en tête
je prends un stock qui est donnée une
fois pour toutes très beau théorème qui
permet de démontrer sa et bien vous ne
pouvez à l'évidence pas avoir une
extraction indéfiniment croissante de ce
stock
vous ne pouvez même pas avoir une
extraction indéfiniment constante de ce
stock parce que sinon votre stock est
infinie en fait les maths vous rappelle
que dans ce genre de cas de figure vous
êtes à 0 à moins l'infini
en ce qui concerne votre extraction
annuel c'est très facile à démontrer
vous serez à 0 à + l'infini chez
raisonnablement facile à démontrer quand
le soleil sera devenue une géante rouge
l'extraction annuelle de pétrole ou de
bauxite sur terre sera devenu nul est
entre les deux vous allez passer par un
maximum absolu c'est à dire que vous
aurez quelque chose qui va ressembler à
ça vous vous rappelez de ce théorème qui
vous dit
quand vous avez une fonction positive et
intégrables et que l'intégrale existe
entre moins l'infini et plus l'infini la
valeur moyenne de cette fonction est nul
à moins d'un fini nul à + l'infini et
passe par un maximum entre les deux
c'est juste une application de ce
théorème donc vous prenez n'importe quel
stocks donnés une fois pour toutes des
hydrocarbures ou n'importe quel minerais
métalliques
vous allez avoir une extraction qui va
connaître un maximum et un déclin
derrière n'importe laquelle
donc quand vous attendez les pétroliers
vous dire oui peut-être que le pic c'est
non la seule question c'est quand et
comment mais le pic est un truc qui est
absolument certain
c'est absolument certain il y en aura un
mad évidemment le débat ne se présente
pas de la même manière selon que le pic
est pour dans cinq ans et aux niveaux
actuels de production ou pour dans trois
millions d'années à 100 fois le niveau
actuel de production évident que les
conséquences qu'on en tire sont pas
exactement les mêmes
par contre il existe alors on va
rapidement voir ce que racontent les
gens du secteur sur les énergies
fossiles
on va commencer par contre le pétrole et
en ce qui concerne le pétrole les
pétrolières aiment bien commencé
l'histoire avec un truc qui s'appelle
les découvertes pour l'excellente raison
que faire sortir de terre du pétrole
qu'on n'a pas découvert est un tantinet
difficile donc on commence par regarder
les découvertes et en fait cette courbe
elle ne elle vous donne une notion est
là lui malheureusement j'ai pas le temps
d'y passer beaucoup de temps mais elle
vous donne une notion qui est la valeur
extractible la plus probable du pétrole
découvert l'adn d'accord donc ce que
vous avez là c'est ce qu'on appelle le
pétrole récupérables c'est pas le
pétrole en place celui qui est sous
terre qui est très différent évidemment
c'est l'évaluation du pétrole
récupérables qu'on fait au moment où on
trace la courbe là vous avez la
production qui n'a pas cessé de croître
alors que vous voyez je pense pas qu'il
ya un lien entre les deux que pas très
loin de l'année de ma naissance
la production s'est mise à décliner la
les découvertes se sont mises à décliner
et elles se sont mises à décliner de
manière très significative à la tendance
ses 45 ans de déclin
évidemment avec des variations si on
considère qu'on a découvert tout le
pétrole existants et si on considère
qu'on a eu d'entrée de jeu la bonne idée
du taux d'extraction du pétrole
découvert alors le pic de production
s'est tout de suite à l'instant où je
vous parle en fait il était même il ya
deux ou trois ans probablement
si on considère que en fait le taux
d'extraction va être un peu supérieure à
l'avenir à l'idée qu'on s'en fait
aujourd'hui est que mais l'idée qu'on
s'en fait aujourd'hui intègre déjà les
progrès
futur d'accord donc en fait ça veut dire
qu'on est conservateur dans notre
optimisme d'une certaine manière et si
on intègre des découvertes à venir mais
dont les pétroliers vous disent tous
comme on a fait dix fois le tour du
propriétaire on va pas le découvrir 25
fois ce qu'on a déjà découvert alors on
parle pas d'un pays qu'on parle d'un
plateau qui commencerait maintenant qui
a commencé il ya deux ans qui commencera
dans trois ans peu importe pour
reprendre le titre d'un excellent
bouquin c'est maintenant donc le vous
voyez vous voyez que le donc la question
de l'approvisionnement en pétrole est
une question qui se pose dès aujourd'hui
et à partir du moment où on rentre dans
un plateau on se trouve dans une
situation dans laquelle tant que la
population continue à croître le quota
disponible par tête des croix donc dès
le moment où l'on rentre dans le plateau
on peut se poser la question de savoir
ce que va devenir le prix du pétrole et
on a toutes les chances de penser qu'il
va se mettre à faire des trucs bizarres
ça paraît assez logique
par ailleurs je signale que pour le
moment 60% du pétrole extrait passe les
frontières que le pétrole est un vrai
marché mondial et dans ce genre de
contexte
rien n'est moins sûr que le fait qu'on
conservera un marché mondial vous aurez
peut-être un premier marché régional
entre les chars américains et les
producteurs irakien un deuxième marché
régional entre les producteurs russes et
les chinois qui sont un peu plus
nombreux que nous à 3e marché régional
entre l'arabie saoudite et je ne sais
pas qui voilà donc et on va la 4e entre
le venezuela et les états unis sont
c'est sûr il existe déjà
donc vous aurez peut-être une succession
de marchés régionaux avec des prix qui
cesseront d'être corréler les uns aux
autres et peut-être que les français
quand ils voudront acheter ce qu'il
restera de pétrole au norvégien hyper
ont trois fois le prix du baril que les
américains paieront au vénézuélien il
n'en savait rien moi non plus tout ce
que je sais c'est que si je suis
banquier ou si je suis administrateur
des budgets de l'état parce que ça vous
concerne aussi tous business plan ou
tout plan pour l'avenir qui suppose que
cette courbe l'aa continue à aller vers
le haut je le jette à la poubelle avant
même de l'avoir regardée alors je vous
signale que d'aller urbaniser le plateau
de saclay pour refaire la bêtise que
vous avez fait ici en mettant tout en
banlieue avec des bagnoles et très
exactement un plan qui marche bien si on
est là et j'ai beaucoup plus de doutes
quant au fait que ça va marcher si on
est là
beaucoup plus de doute et je pense
qu'ici il va se passer des choses aussi
d'une manière générale dès que vous avez
organisé l'avenir dans un monde dans
lequel la disponibilité future de
l'énergie n'est pas un problème si elle
se met à devenir un problème
comme disait monsieur de la palisse vous
allez en avoir un alors qu'est-ce que
les pétroliers nous dise dans cette
affaire je vais vous faire ici le
parcours du discours de total
parce que je trouve que c'est très
instructif en monsieur 2000 quand
monsieur desmarest pardon en 2004 donc
des marais est toujours l'actuel
président de total mais à l'époque il
était président en plus des jets il
avait un discours que je trouvais d'un
jésuitisme consommer qui consistait à
tester l'hypothèse sans trop s'avancer
donc ce que disait monsieur démarré à
l'époque c'est moi j'ai pas d'idée sur
le moment où la production va passer par
un pic
sauf que y en avait une quand même
évidemment et ceux qui en parlent
parlent de 2010 à 2030
puis alors hier il a regardé les
réactions du monde ambiant il a constaté
que la presse s'en foutait comme de l'an
40 donc il s'est dit je peux aller un
peu plus loin et à ce moment il s'est
mis à dire que le pic elle est arrivée
en 2001 et que ça enfin avant 2020
pardon et que la production allait ne
dépassera jamais 100 millions $ us par
jour
et puis après harry big moustache qui
dit moi je pense que c'est la fougue de
la jeunesse donc moi je pense que ça
sera avant 2015 et que nous
n'atteindrons jamais 95 millions de
barils par jour
et puis bien qu'il ait pris deux ans le
même devient un peu plus jeunes en 2009
et il dit moi je pense que ce sera avant
2015 mais que ce sera sous 90 il avait
dissous 89 millions de barils par jour
et en 2008 on était à 87
donc ce que je vous dis c'est maintenant
ce qui va se passer à partir de
maintenant le plus vraisemblable et
c'est le pari que fait l'homme qui a
fait ce graphique là qui est géologue à
l'institut français du pétrole
c'est que à partir de maintenant la
production va zigzag houllier autour
d'un plateau est évidemment la
production va évoluer en fonction de
pape contraintes qui ne sont pas des
contraintes purement géologiques
alors voilà un autre
une autre déclaration intéressante il ya
un monsieur qui s'appelle claude mandil
a encore un x mines puisque j'ai entendu
quelqu'un dire ça tout à l'heure à
propos de démarrer avec l'âge et
s'améliore donc monsieur claude mandil
dirige l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie aie puis au moment où ils step
down
il fait un truc monsieur claude mandil
qui est de publier un rapport qui
l'envoie à françois fillon alors
françois fillon devait être plus
intéressés par ce circuit de la sarthe
ce jour-là que par le rapport qu'il
avait reçus parce que dans ce rapport il
était écrit ceci en hausse en avril 2008
1 et il est écrit cela nous sommes en
avril 2008 avec un baril qui est déjà à
plus de 100 dollars le baril et déjà
plus de 100 $ et mende il dit on
pourrait connaître des excursions prix
très importantes
donc en fait ce que ce truc dit en creux
ou en tout cas on peut le comprendre
comme ça c'est que même 100 dollars le
baril c'est pas du tout un maximum
garanti qu on pourrait très bien avoir
beaucoup plus est alors un truc moi qui
m'interpelle de manière assez
significative
voilà la manière dont va évoluer le prix
du baril depuis juin 2008 donc s'est
monté à des sommets c'est redescendu à
du très bas on était à 40 dollars le
baril aujourd'hui c'est remonté à 60 à
jamais dans l'histoire de l'humanité le
pétrole n'a repris 50% en période de
récession comme celle qu'on est en train
de connaître actuellement jamais alors
moi je sais pas si c'est un signe
en tout cas je sais que c'est un point
d'interrogation faut vraiment se poser
la question de savoir qu'est ce que
c'est que ce truc là
et monsieur desmarest pardon monsieur de
margerie a dit y'a pas longtemps qu'il
n'était pas du tout sûr que le pétrole
allaient rester ça jusqu'à la fin de la
récession actuelle et qu'il était
parfaitement possible que à cause des
contraintes sur la production
on est de nouveau une explosion sur les
prix avant la fin de la récession
actuelle
ce qui fait qu'à ce moment tous les
braves gens qui sont en train de
s'agiter au gouvernement et ailleurs en
dix ans bientôt la sortie de la crise va
nous permettre deux peut-être que non
alors on n'a pas de pétrole y'a qu'à
utiliser du gaz est bien même motif même
punition le maximum des découvertes
annuelles de gaz c'était il ya quarante
ans et le maximum de la production
annuelle de gaz c'est dans dix ans on va
dire plus ou moins cinq ans
il faut savoir qu'actuellement l'europe
en tant que zone géographique donc je
mets la norvège dedans produits 30% de
son pétrole et que cette production en
baisse de 10% par an et 40% de son gaz
qui va plafonner très bientôt et ensuite
descendre et quand la production
européenne de gaz descendra on pourra
descendre dans la rue pour violer quand
les augmentations de prix et le fait que
monsieur poutine est un [ __ ] pour la
gueule et tant qu'on veut ça ne change
on créera pas de gaz dans le gisement de
mer du nord n'en fera pas une goutte est
ce que il ya un lien entre le prix du
pétrole les prix de l'économie va vous
avez compris que c'était ma thèse
mais c'est pas ma thèse parce que j'ai
trouvé ça tout seul dans mon coin c'est
ma thèse parce que on observe des trucs
comme ça
ici vous avez alors c'est pas la même
année de référence mais vous avez le
qu'est ce que je veux dire le prix du
baril en dollars constants vous voyez
c'est l'évolution que je vous ai montré
tout à l'heure et en grisé vous allez
vous avez lé moment où l'économie
mondiale a ralenti et les pays
occidentaux ont connu des récessions et
bien vous voyez qu'il n'existe pas un
hockey sur le prix du pétrole qui ne
soit pas suivie par soit un
ralentissement économique soit une
récession franche c'est ce qu'on est en
train de vivre en ce moment et c'est
parfaitement logique puisque les prix du
pétrole pilote le prix de toutes les
énergies
le prix d' énergie ces prix de la
transformation donc il est normal que si
vous avez une hausse forte du prix du
pétrole vous ayez une feinte freinage de
la transformation est donc un
ralentissement économique voire une
récession
alors maintenant vous mettez boutabout
ce truc là est ce que je vous ai raconté
sur le plafonnement de l'offre
pétrolière et le fait qu'on a construit
un monde qui en termes de structure de
métier d'urbanisme etc
je vous fais pas la chanson est
totalement dépendant d'énergie abondante
et à bas prix et posez vous la question
de savoir ce que devient la stabilité
socio économiques dans le monde dans
lequel on va dire pendant les vingt ans
qui viennent
je pense qu'on sous estime gravement les
risques que cette affaire fait peser au
dessus de nos têtes
autre illustration de la même chose ici
vous avez la mise en perspective du prix
du baril aux états unis et du taux de
chômage l'année qui suit alors encore
une fois corrélation ne veut pas dire
cause mais c'est cohérent avec une
explication dans laquelle l'énergie fait
d'économies qui et c'est là les états
unis sont autosuffisant en pétrole là
ils commencent à en importer sur les
marchés mondiaux de plus en plus et vous
voyez qu'on n'écrit pas exactement la
même histoire en ce qui concerne la
corrélation de la courbe des deux côtés
alors plus de pétrole et plus de gaz
mettons nous au charbon même motif même
punition le charbon est un stock fini
les fougères du carbonifère ne
toucheront pas une deuxième fois et donc
le pitch charbon même en tirant sur le
charbon tant qu'on peut c'est une
génération à partir de maintenant une
génération et demi donc il faut pas
croire que tout ça est un problème pour
les générations futures
tout ça est un problème pour les gens
qui sont dans cette salle c'est un
problème pour les générations actuelles
actuelle c'est absolument pas un
problème pour les générations futures
ça aussi c'est n'importe quoi c'est un
problème pour les générations actuelles
donc à chaque fois que vous voyez un
journaliste employer le terme
générations futures s'il vous plaît
engueuler le 10 puis qui se met le doigt
dans l'oeil et qu'il est en train de
parler d'une échéance qui est lointaine
alors que l'échéance
je répète c'est maintenant
qu'est ce que ça va donner le jo
géopolitique de cette affaire dans un
monde contre un sur la partie amont
vous avez ici un graphique qui vous
donne les réserves prouvées agrégé de
charbon de gaz et de pétrole dans le
monde
alors le pétrole normalement vous y
arrivez oil le gaz est là et le charbon
est là et surprise
qui est-ce qui a les plus grosses
réserves de carbone souterrain dans le
monde c'est notre ami obama
et ceci explique cela c'est à cause de
ça que les états unis ont toujours été
extrêmement réticent à s'engager dans
quoi que ce soit en ce qui compte en ce
qui concerne la convention climat et
vous verrez qu'ils sont pas les seuls
après on va trouver la vie poutine qui a
la bonne idée d'avoir les premières
réserves de gaz de la planète et qui a
un peu de pétrole quand même pas mal et
qui a les deuxièmes réserves de charbon
de la planète
après on va trouver nos amis indiens et
chinois qui ont les troisièmes et
quatrièmes réserves de charbon de la
planète après on va trouver la mire
ahmadinejad qui en gaz et pétrole agrégé
à les premières réserves du moyen-orient
donc vous comprenez qu'on n'a pas très
envie d'être méchant avec lui ensuite
vous avez l'arabie saoudite qui a les
premières réserves de pétrole de la
planète sauf si le canada on
comptabilise les sables bitumineux du
canada auquel cas ils jouent à peu près
dans la même cour que l'arabie saoudite
mais vous voyez qu'en terme de carbone
globale
ça change par contre considérablement la
donne donc ça veut dire que le graphique
que je vous ai montré juste avant un
c'est pas d'augmenter l'air sous une de
ses courbes de 5 % ou 2 3% qui va
changer considérablement la forme de la
courbe 1 ap hp grand chose dont je
reviens à mon amont machin est alors
regardons qui s'est intéressé au
protocole de kyoto ce qui va faire la
transition
deux pays dans la dans le peloton de
tête en ont fait une ratification
tardive
la russie qui a été le dernier pays du
paquet qui a permis l'entrée en vigueur
du protocole à le ratifier en 2005
protocole date 2,97 donc ils ont quand
même pris leur temps nos amis russes et
l'australie qui l'a ratifié à la faveur
de la dernière élection législative qui
a changer la majorité au pouvoir
ça c'était au début de l'année où à la
fin de l'année dernière tous les autres
ils ont dit qu'is fera rien ils ont dit
qu'ils feraient rien soit qu'ils aient
signé un protocole qu'ils ont pas
ratifié derrière cas des états unis soit
qu'ils aient ratifié un protocole qui ne
comporte aucune contrainte pour eux cas
de l'inde et de la chine
d'accord tout cela ils ont dit pour le
moment qui ferait rien donc l'essentiel
du carbone restant sous terre est détenu
par des pays qui pour le moment ont
refusé de prendre le moindre engagement
sur la limitation de leurs émissions
propres alors évidemment ça concerne
quand même les pays qui vont importer
ces combustibles et qui vont s'en servir
sauf que le charbon aujourd'hui c'est 5%
du charbon qui franchit les frontières
le charbon est une énergie domestique
c'est pas une énergie de marché
international donc ça pose évidemment la
question de savoir ce que tous ces
braves gens vont faire de leur charbon
domestique qui va être consommée pour
l'essentiel de manière domestique alors
là ils ont trois options
la première est de dire pauvre petit
français champions du camembert et du
champagne on a pitié de vous parce que
dans un climat qui sera celui de
l'algérie faire du camembert du
champagne ce sera dur donc on va garder
notre carbone sous le sol
payet new logic moitié des repas c'est
ce que je ferais pineau deuxième option
ces braves gens ont des électeurs vous
allez voir que tous ces braves gens ont
des électeurs sauf la chine mais tous
les autres ont des électeurs dans qu'ils
disent mais ça fait pas beaucoup la
chine assure la population mondiale
globale ça fait beaucoup en valeur
absolue mais beaucoup d'électeurs donc
tous ces braves gens ont des électeurs
et les électeurs disent je veux du
carburant pour mettre dans ma bagnole
parce que sinon c'est dégueulasse le
monde est injuste et à ce moment ces
gens-là construisent à vitesse accélérée
des usines de liquéfaction du charbon
marche très bien
les nazis ont fait avancer les chars et
les avions avec ça marche très bien les
sud africains ont fait avancer leurs
bannières avec ça marche très bien donc
il y kéfi du charbon juste assez pour
servir leur marché domestique parce que
quand même ces bestioles coût de
quelques milliards de dollars pièce et
qu'on se remplir et lyon fra en contexte
récessif donc juste pour servir
et puis les autres allez vous faire voir
donc à ce moment les braves petits
français et les braves petits européens
se retrouvent dans un monde dans lequel
on a droit aux changements climatiques
engendrés par les émissions des autres
et pas les combustibles fossiles
disponible chez les autres voilà je vous
fais pas de dessin je pense que les
promesses électorales dans ce genre de
cas de figure vous pouvez assez
largement les oublier et le troisième
cas de figure est évidemment qui
liquéfie à tout va pour servir aussi des
marchés à l'export et à ce moment
vous retrouvez dans ce contexte là où de
toute façon vous êtes dans une impasse à
l'échelle d'une génération
et en plus vous prenez une addition
climatique sur la figure qui aura toutes
les chances d'être pas très sympathique
pour ceux qui auront à la gérer alors ce
petit tableau fermé faire la transition
ce petit tableau dit qu'en fonction du
moment où on passera le maximum de la
consommation d'énergie fossile donc le
maximum des émissions de co2
modulo la capture et séquestration dont
on parlera peut-être tout à l'heure et
bien là le delta de température
planétaire que vous aurez à l'arrivée et
toutes ces estimations comme vous le
savez très bien sont conservatrices
parce que l'essentiel des mécanismes de
rétroaction amplificateur sont pour le
moment très mal évalué dans les outils
de modélisation qui sont disponibles et
malheureusement il a plus
d'amplificateurs que d'amortisseur ça
veut dire que en gros le moment où on va
passer le pic des émissions de co2 est
absolument fondamental pour savoir dans
quel climat vivront nos enfants et
petits-enfants donc c'est un autre
génération là tout de suite et
maintenant qu'il incombe la
responsabilité et on a déjà perdu
beaucoup de temps de faire ce qu'il faut
pour que l'on soit pas là mais là parce
que sinon encore une fois cette addition
là sera totalement ingérable par les
gens qu'auront à la gérer et à ce moment
là je pense que plutôt que de payer les
retraites
ils mettront les vieillards qui ont été
responsables de cette affaire en prison
en tout cas moi j'aurais assez envie à
leur place de le faire si on veut se
limiter à le pic en 2000 ou 2010 ça veut
dire qu'on a encore le droit d'envoyer
dans l'atmosphère avec un flux des
croissants j'insiste avec un flux des
croissants la quantité de carbone
contenu dans les réserves prouvées de
gaz et de pétrole donc c'est même pas la
totalité de ses textiles de ce qui est
extractible et c'est tout pas de charbon
c'est un monde sans charbon ça veut dire
qu'un des enjeux dans cette affaire donc
que faire contre la contrainte carbone
eh bien on a au moins une idée assez
claire c'est se débarrasser le plus vite
possible des centrales à charbon sans
dispositif de capture et séquestration
l'électricité coûtera ce qu'elle coûtera
mais c'est le truc à faire à vitesse
accélérée
voilà donc on va passer à l'aspect aval
de cette histoire
je ne veux pas en entendre un seul me
dire vivement 2015 je vous préviens et
on va retrouver donc ici la perturbation
bon jeu fonctionnement du système
climatique vous connaissez mieux que moi
donc on va jouer juste vous parlez de la
perturbation du fonctionnement
climatique qui est induite par sa entre
autre chose c'est-à-dire les émissions
humaines de co2 et vous voyez que les
émissions humaines de co2 comme la
consommation d'énergie croise quand la
croissance économique
et quand la bêtise accident de parcours
elle se elle s'arrête
du reste 2009 va être une très bonne
année pour les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre très bonne année je prends les
paris avec qui veut 2009 va être une
excellente année quand vous avez une
très grosse récession ce qui s'est passé
dans les pays de l'est après la chute du
mur de berlin vous avez une contraction
de plusieurs dizaines de pour cent des
émissions de co2 alors comme ce truc là
peut pas grimper jusqu'au ciel mais va
se mettre à baisser à cause de la
contrainte sur les combustibles fossiles
je suis en train de vous rappeler une
fois de plus que si c'est pas nous qui
le giron de manière volontaire et ça
sera très désagréable c'est des trucs
encore pire qui s'en chargeront à notre
place ce co2 ou est-ce qui va ça vous le
connaissez probablement ce co2
c'est en qui l'a signifie pour un tiers
dans les écosystèmes continentaux qui
sont susceptibles en recracher une
partie plus tard et pour la moitié dans
l'atmosphère actuellement ce qui veut
dire que c'est le seuil de ce qu'on doit
faire l'effort minimum de ce qu'on doit
faire c'est diviser les émissions
mondiales de co2 par de azap aussi vite
que possible et en fait comme c'est un
système dynamique il faut maintenant
même les divisé par trois mais je vous
montrerai tout à l'heure ce que ça
signifie de diviser par 2 vous allez
comprendre que c'est quand même pas une
partie de plaisir
si je rajoute le méthane et le protoxyde
et que je regarde d'où viennent mes
émissions voilà ce que ça donne dans le
monde
alors tout ce qui n'est pas dans
l'ellipse et du co2 le reste c'est pas
du co2 pour l'essentiel est ici vous
allez trouver les centrales à charbon et
des raffineries et les centrales à gaz
rappelez vous que les centrales à
charbon à elle toute seule c'est 20% du
co2 mondiales
c'est à dire plus que les moyens de
transport qui en font 17 donc les
centrales à charbon ou le charbon voici
d'ennemis je le répète
en france on en n'est pas assez
conscients parce qu'on n'a pas
d'exploitation charbonnières parce qu'on
n'a pas d'industrie charbonnière mais le
charbon voici l'ennemi encore une fois
j'insiste vraiment là-dessus les
transports etc
alors ce que vous constatez c'est que
rien de ce que vous faites dans une
journée ordinaire n'échappe aux
émissions de gaz à effet de serre donc
j'en reviens à la question posée que
faire face à la contrainte carbone va y
avoir touché à tout il n'existe pas de
solution à ce truc lara qui souhaite une
solution détachable qu'on peut confier
un ingénieur en lui disant des maires de
toit du problème dans ton coin
moi je veux pas en entendre parler je
veux rester assis dans mon canapé et que
tu trouve une solution
c'est pas possible ça n'est pas possible
donc ce truc là ne se règlent qu'en
touchant à tous et si c'est la solution
à volontaires qui s'applique de type
guerre récession massive et aidera de
façon ça touchera tout donc encore une
fois penser que qui que ce soit dans
cette salle serait en dehors de l'effort
qu'il va falloir faire pour régler ce
problème est à l'heure moi compris c'est
un leurre c'est pas comme ça que les
choses doivent se passer
je vous rappelle simplement parce que
vous le savez mieux que moi qu'une
simulation climatique commence par un
scénario qui est fait sur l'évolution de
l'humanité à l'avenir et donc que vous
n'avez pas de résultats qui sont
indépendants de l'hypothèse que vous
avez mis en entrée ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on oublie souvent
la deuxième chose qu'on oublie souvent
c'est que comme on est sur des processus
lesquels on appris la boucle de
rétroaction à l'intérieur du système
mais pas le contrôle de cohérence sur
l'hypothèse en entrée toutes les
simulations sont faites à l'échelle du
siècle sans qu'on se pose une seule
seconde la question de savoir s'il ya un
moment ou à un autre la dérive
climatique observé reste compatible ou
non avec une humanité de 8 puis 9 puis
10 puis 11 milliards de bons hommes qui
se mettent à consommer de plus en plus
parce que mon sentiment c'est que si
vous changez la température planétaire
de 5 degrés en un siècle vous aurez pas
12 milliards de bonshommes à l'arrivée
on aurait beaucoup moins que ça alors ça
ça a un effet majeur que vous connaissez
peut-être certains d'entre vous c'est
que à partir du moment où toutes les
simulations vont jusqu'à l'échéance
cela accrédite l'idée dans le grand
public qui peut rien se passer
catastrophique avant le 31 décembre 2099
réfléchissez-y bien c'est exactement ça
qui se passe donc le grand public
s'imagine que ce truc là c'est
éventuellement un problème pour ou là où
c'est loin même avec les minettes
afflelou donc c'est quelque chose qui
est vraiment vraiment très important à
garder en mémoire c'est alors ça peut
paraître idiot un mois il m'a fallu un
certain temps pour m'en rendre compte
que le simple fait encore une fois de
donner toujours les simulations jusqu'à
l'échéance accrédite de ce seul fait
l'idée que vous avez pas de catastrophe
avant qui bien évidemment est à mon avis
quelque chose de complètement faux et
pour s'en convaincre ça c'est aussi
quelque chose que vous connaissez
sûrement
il suffit de se rappeler que le delta de
température moyenne entre le dernier
maximum glaciaire et aujourd'hui c'est
juste 5 degrés de moyenne planétaire et
c'est quelque chose qui a mis dix mille
ans à ceux enfin le réchauffement qui a
permis de passer du dernier maximum
glaciaire a aujourd'hui s'est effectuée
en dix mille ans en changeant de manière
absolument massive la géographie
planétaire et des conditions de vie sur
terre donc mon sentiment c'est que le
même genre de transition appliqué à une
humanité sédentaires de 7 milliards de
bons hommes parce que là il y avait cinq
millions de sédentaires 1,7 milliard de
bonshommes en un siècle ça se termine en
van sant c'est mon sentiment c'est à
dire que le déplacement des conditions
favorables y aura considérablement trop
vite pour que des sociétés sédentaires
et repus s'adapte à ce genre de
changement dans la joie et la bonne
humeur
donc ça se terminera en pugilat donc
quand on donne le prix nobel de la paix
au giec
je pense qu'on fait pas d'erreur de
casting c'est vraiment il s'agit
vraiment de sens
bon quelques petits trucs que vous
connaissez aussi ça chauffera pas de la
même manière partout où je vais aller
vite ça chauffera pas alors un truc
aussi que sur lequel moi j'aime beaucoup
insisté c'est que le cycle de l'eau qui
est plus déterminant pour les
écosystèmes installé que la variation de
température en général va aussi subir
des modifications
alors ça je le dis juste pour rappeler
que la presse parle toujours de la
température est très peu de la
modification du cycle de l'eau alors que
le facteur limitant pour une bonne
partie des bestioles et des plantes
c'est ça beaucoup plus que le que le que
la température et il faut presque aller
encore un cran au delà parce qu'il ya
une bonne partie des plantes pour
lesquelles ce qui va vraiment content et
c'est moins l'eau qui tombe que l'eau
qui reste dans le sol donc en fait c'est
l'évolution de l'humidité des sols qui
est le truc qui peut aussi être limitant
alors là vous voyez par exemple que tout
le pourtour du bassin méditerranéen vers
lé sol s'assécher verrait les
précipitations diminué en toute saison
donc l'union pour la méditerranée on a
au moins un thème à lui trouvé cette
combattre la sécheresse
essart et nous convaincre et ça va nous
concerne et nous aussi aussi voilà après
il ya des tas d'autres trucs qui vont
arriver avec évidemment d ampleur qui
son scénario dépendantes
il va se passer des choses sur les
écosystèmes installé il va se passer des
choses sur les agents pathogènes plus on
chauffe le bouillon de culture et plus
les petites bestioles m
il va se passer des choses sur le niveau
de l'océan avec là aussi des
discontinuités qui pourrait se produire
qui sont mal mais des discontinuités à
la hausse
il va y avoir une élévation des
températures c'est évident et retenez
que si la température planétaire s'élève
de 3 degrés on a en europe 1 et et 2003
qui devient en était à peu près normale
à peu près normale c'est à dire que un
été sur deux peluches c'est le sommet de
lagos yens il va se passer des choses
sur la modification de la dérive dans
l'atlantique là aussi mal évalué il va
se passer des choses sur les phénomènes
de convection violente qui restitue de
l'énergie du sol vers l'atmosphère donc
notamment tout ce qui est hors nador à
jour à gants etc
quand je dis va se passer des choses
personne ne sait exactement ce qu'il
peut se passer parce que vous avez à
faire là des modèles qui sont sous la
maille donc pour les jeanjean bombay en
gros ça paraît logique que toutes les
manifestations de restitution d'énergie
du sol vers l'atmosphère s'intensifie
quand vous modifiez le delta de
température entre le soleil atmosphère
c'est un truc qui heurte pas tellement
le bon sens après on va continuer à
avoir des problèmes aussi avec les
calottes glaciaires alors celle du
groenland et problement déjà en train de
se désagréger
et celle de l'antarctique de l'ouest
pour suivre également il va y avoir une
acidification de l'océan ce qui va poser
des problèmes à toutes les bestioles qui
synthétise du calcaire et enfin vous
pourriez avoir relargages dans
l'atmosphère de carbone qui est
temporairement stockées aujourd'hui dans
les écosystèmes terrestres voire de
carbone qui a été stocké il ya très
longtemps et sous d'autres formes
dans le sol gelé en permanence des
hautes latitudes soit sous forme de
carbone brut
philippe ciais pour ceux qui le
connaissent vous en parlerez vieux que
moi soit sous forme d'hydrates de
méthane
c'est à dire de cristaux mixte donc
voilà la liste des plaisanteries
possible est longue et c'est surtout ça
moi que je retiens c'est à dire que
quand on est en train de faire une
exception vous devez apprendre ça quand
on fait une expérience grandeur nature
sur un système complexe et multi
déterminé que on n'a jamais approché
autrement qu'en équation simple la
probabilité pour qu'on est tous venir à
l'avance est à peu près nulles donc il
va se passer des choses qu'on n'aura pas
vu venir à l'avance un truc qu'on voit
pas venir à l'avant c'est une surprise
et une surprise c'est un truc auquel on
sait pas s'adapter
alors si elle est bonne tant mieux si
elle est mauvaise tant pis et si je
remet en perspective les deux problèmes
dont je viens de vous parler
voilà comment va évoluer la consommation
de combustibles fossiles
donc les émissions de co2 dans tous les
cas de figure il va y avoir un maximum
puis déclin à cause de mes foutu
intégral et c'est pas au moment où je
passe le maximum des émissions que je
stabilise le thermostat c'est à dire que
je stabilise la quantité de co2 le stock
atmosphériques de co2 c'est ce que
louise est à l'heure il faut revenir à
la moitié au tiers et puis après il faut
continuer à descendre du reste alors en
démocratie il va falloir expliquer aux
gens qui votent que au moment où on fait
des efforts la situation le premier
paramètre observable qui la quantité de
co2 dans l'atmosphère continuent de
monter dans vous allez avoir du boulot
ensuite il va falloir leur expliquer que
alors qu'on fait des efforts la
température continue de monter donc on
va aussi avoir du boulot
et enfin il va falloir leur expliquer
que au moment où on fait des efforts la
dérive océanique continue d'augmenter
donc on va avoir encore plus de boulot
alors maintenant si ça c'est le flux
c'est le fruit de la limitation du stock
et non pas de notre volonté
ça veut pas dire qu'on a un problème qui
en a évacué un autre ça veut dire qu'on
a deux ans maire de man sur les bras au
même moment c'est à dire à la fois à la
diminution de l'énergie pas cher et
facile d'emploi c'est-à-dire ce qui
permet de modifier l'environnement à
notre profit et une augmentation du
problème environnemental à gérer bonjour
l'ambiance ça risque de pas être très
sympathique pour ceux qui devront
rsa et ceux qui devront gérer ça les
plus jeunes dans la salle en font
problème en partie donc c'est pas un
problème encore une fois qui est pour
dans des lustres alors si on veut régler
ce problème qu'est ce qu'on doit faire
aujourd'hui voilà à quoi ressemble les
émissions de carbone par personne et par
an à la surface de la planète vous
constatez bien évidemment une très
grande disparité selon que vous êtes
dans un pays dit riches ou dans un pays
dits pauvres
je vous rappelle que même un indien il a
déjà selon la manière dont vous allez
faire le calcul entre 10 et 30 esclaves
énergétique par personne à sa
disposition un donc encore une fois
rappelez vous que la pauvreté ça n'est
que la partie gauche de la distribution
revenus sains pour supprimer la pauvreté
fowler d'irak pas d'autre solution
quand vous avez une gaussienne dans
votre courbe de répartition des revenus
vous avez de la pauvreté par définition
par définition puisque c'est toute la
partie de la courbe qui est en dessous
d'une d'un certain pourcentage de la
valeur médiane d'accord donc supprimer
la pauvreté c'est un non sens
mathématique réduire les inégalités
ça c'est possible réduire l'écart type
supprimer la pauvreté c'est
mathématiquement impossible sauf à avoir
un d'irak anticipions donc j'en reviens
à ce que je disais non je vous dis ça
parce que encore une fois il ya des
notions pour lesquels on considère qu'on
comprend ce que ça veut dire alors qu'en
fait on comprend pas du tout ce que ça
veut dire c'est pas moi j'ai vécu
jusqu'à 40 ans et qu'elles qui sans
savoir ce que c'était que la définition
de la pauvreté
quand vous regardez ce que c'est comme
définition vous vous rendez compte qu'il
ya des affirmations qui tiennent pas la
route
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut pas vivre
dans un monde plus juste pour ça que
j'entends dire alors je reviens à ce que
je disais donc ici vous avez votre
répartition des émissions de carbone et
le trait horizontal rouge c'est la
location à laquelle nous avons droit à
chacun d'entre nous dans un monde qui
n'auraient pas vu sa population croître
et dans lequel on aurait dit viser les
émissions mondiales de co2 par deux
et si on fait une division par trois et
qu'on fait croître la population on est
au trait bleu donc le monde du
développement durable à quelque part
entre les émissions actuelles d'un
indien les émissions actuelles d'un
brésilien c'est ça notre objectif il
faut que aussi vite que possible
les émissions moyennes d'un français
reviennent au niveau actuel des
émissions d'un indien ou d'un brésilien
ne pensez pas une seconde que ces gens
là vont pouvoir monter jusqu'au niveau
des émissions moyennes qu'on a ici la
boîte implose avant ça n'arrivera pas ça
n'arrivera
pas de répéter une troisième fois en
france ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on
apprenne à se contenter de soixante
esclaves énergétique par personne alors
pour est-ce que je n'ai pas fait une
division par 4 dans cette histoire
puisqu'il s'agit du facteur 4 là bas
parce que j'ai trente esclaves
énergétique qui viennent du nucléaire et
de l'hydraulique
je me l'égard des faux pas de co2 et les
120 qui reste j'étais à 150 au début les
120 qui aurait gelé divise par quatre
salles en fait 30 donc lavées 30 sans
co2 plus 30 accès aux deux femmes ont
fait 60
si je veux a l'occasion me débarrasser
aussi du nucléaire j'en ai plus de 30
question de choix alors ce quota et là
vous allez voir que même vous vous êtes
over quotas avec quoi est-ce qu'il est
atteint il est atteint avec vous monter
dans un avion je crois savoir que les
chercheurs montrent de temps en temps
dans un avion dès que vous avez utilisé
quelques milliers de kilowatts heure
pour faire une expérience par exemple
parce que pour avoir fait le bilan
carbone du cea à saclay je sais que de
certaines expériences consomment des
quantités d'électricité non négligeable
dès que vous avez acheté un microscope
électronique alors out même pas la peine
d'en parler et complètement exploser
votre quota mais quand vous avez acheté
un ordinateur et demi vous avez aussi
exposer votre quota pour faire ça vous
émettez à peu près 300 kg de carbone
c'est toute l'électricité fait aux
combustibles fossiles dans les pays dans
lesquels vous fabriquer les
semi-conducteurs c'est toute l'énergie
consommée pour faire la chimie de
spécialité et la chimie de base
dans l'autre sens plutôt qui vont
permettre de faire les composants de
l'ordinateur c'est toute l'énergie qu'on
a dépensé pour fabriquer les usines
transporter les pièces etc etc
donc ça c'est 300 kg de combustible
fossile donc la civilisation internet
dématérialisée je refais référence à
zazie et vous savez ce qu'elle disait
c'est bon c'est absolument pas vrai vous
construisez 4 mètres carrés de logements
vous avez épuisé votre quota vous
chauffez un bout de maison pendant un
mois vous avez épuisé votre quota et
vous venez travailler ici toute l'année
en voiture vous avez épuisé votre côté
si vous avez payé votre quota ça veut
dire qu'une fois que vous avez fait ça
vous n'avez plus droit à rien de tout ça
donc vous devez trouver quelqu'un qui
n'a même pas fait ça et lui acheter le
bout de quotas qui lui reste pour avoir
le droit de
vous chauffer ou d'acheter un peu
d'électricité ou d'acheter une chaise ou
de etc les jeunes dans cette salle vont
se dire ce mec là est insupportable
parce que ça c'est le monde dans lequel
je vis il n'est pas question de le
supprimer
alors moi je suis pas quelqu'un qui est
un coupeur de têtes par vocation
par contre je constate simplement que
tous ces trucs là sont extrêmement
récent c'est à dire qu'il ya 50 ans il y
avait pas une chambre à coucher par
enfant n'y avait pas l'avion
démocratique y avait pas la voiture
démocratique avait pas les supermarchés
démocratique et il n'y avait pas de
chauffage central dans toutes les
maisons il n'y avait pas d'électricité
dans toutes les maisons non plus
respectables jean jouzel que vous
connaissez tous sûrement dans cette
salle est né dans une ferme à janzé il
ya 60 ans il est né dans une ferme à
janzé en bretagne il n'y avait pas de
chauffage central
y'avait pas l'électricité il y avait
évidemment pas de voiture d'accord il a
60 ans donc tous ces trucs là qu'on
considère aujourd'hui comme acquis pour
l'éternité sont extrêmement récent est
extrêmement fragile dans le contexte
énergétique dans lequel nous vivons et
il est assez vraisemblable que ça va pas
tenir à l'avenir même si on fait des
efforts considérables sur le reste des
énergies et on y vient c'est avec ça
trois petites additions que je vais
conclure ou trois petites multiplication
eux on va utiliser ses moyens c'est la
règle de trois qui tue pour moi on dit
que les émissions je les rends égal aux
émissions de co2 ce sur quoi on devrait
être d'accord et après je les divisent
et je les multiplie par la consommation
énergétique mondiale le pib mondial et
la population mondiale ce qui me permet
de dire que mes émissions de gaz
carbonique sont égales à ça qui est le
contenu en gaz carbonique de l'énergie
ça qui est l'intensité énergétique de
l'économie ça qui est le pib par
personne ce qui a peu de choses près et
le pouvoir d'achat par personne et ça
c'est la population jeudi également que
si je mets ce terme là sous contrainte
ce que j'ai envie de faire eh ben je
dois pouvoir retrouver ma contraintes
dans la manière dont ces termes là vont
évoluer
alors je commence à m le terme de gauche
sous contrainte et je dis je veux
diviser par deux asap
et je dis même du reste que à cause de
mes fiches intégral bornes et façon
viendra un moment où ça arrivera et où
forêt or les émissions de co2 de
l'humanité seront inférieurs à la moitié
de ce qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
c'est juste une question de temps
alors après je vais aller voir
l'institut national d'études
démographiques où il ya des collègues à
vous et je leur demander est ce que la
population mondiale va être divisé par
deux dans les 41 ans qui viennent
il m'explique que sow grippe aviaire ou
autres plaisanteries de ce genre non ce
qu'ils voient c'est que l'on va gagner
on va monter à 9 milliards donc on va
gagner 35 % entre maintenant et 2050
donc si là je dois divisé par deux et
que là je commence par x 1,35
c'est que j'ai du chemin à faire sur le
reste alors le chemin à faire sur le
reste et en gros une division par 2
quelque chose dont je vais voir monsieur
attali et je lui demande s'il envisage
de diviser le pib par personne par
devenir lui quelque chose et attali
m'explique que non cela étant un quart
d'heure après pourrait m'expliquer
qui'il ça dérange pas et que je les ai
vécus personnellement donc rencontré
l'anecdote après si ça vous amuse donc
2% de croissance par an bah vous êtes
comme moi champion des intérêts composés
même si vous n'êtes pas banquier ça vous
fait 1,02 à la puissance 41 ça vous fait
une multiplication par un petit facteur
deux et demi à l'échéance d'accord donc
là j'ai x 1,3 et là par deux et demi ce
qui veut dire que si je dois ici / 2
demain tout l'effort est apportée sur ce
que j'appelle ici magic technique magic
technique c'est pas trop les gens comme
vous c'est plutôt les gens qui viennent
après c'est à dire les ingénieurs donc
vous avez deux catégories dans magic
technique vous avez les ingénieurs qui
vous savent faire des cafetières
essentiels comme vous avez compris plus
efficaces donc j'achète lorraine
cafetière qui a été fabriqué avec moins
d'énergie et qui va consommer moins
d'énergie alors en fait avec nespresso
c'est faux je vous dis tout de suite
celle inverse ce essaimé partout à tous
les usages consomment de plus en plus
d'énergie dans un monde dans lequel le
prix réel de l'énergie baissent
important est ici c'est la deuxième
catégorie d'ingénieurs qui font magic
technique c'est ce qu'ils vont me faire
de l'énergie finale avec le moins de co2
possible d'accord donc ils vont me
remplacer mais centrales à charbon par
des centrales nucléaires à des éoliennes
ils vont me remplacer mais centrales à
charbon par des centrales à gaz ils vont
me remplacer les centrales à charbon par
les centrales à charbon et capture et
séquestration etc
c'est ça qui vont faire alors je
convoque la première catégorie
d'ingénieurs et je leur demande ce
qu'ils fiche et ils me disent bas
monsieur depuis 35 ans on a réussi à
gagner 30%
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui pour faire 1
dollars de pib faut consommer 30 %
d'énergie en moins que ya 35 ans alors
je dis ça c'est vachement bien
et je considère qu'un point par an en
chine en ordre de grandeur
faites-moi grâce de la composition des
intérêts je prolonge et je dis qu'on va
gagner 40% sur les quarante ans qui
viennent
là on a eu deux chocs pétroliers on a
fait beaucoup plus d'efforts que ce
qu'on a fait les années qui viennent de
s'écouler
donc on en a fait un des efforts sur les
économies donc au jeu fait une
prolongation d'un truc un peu ambitieux
et à ce moment je me rends compte que
sur les 40 ans qui viennent il faut
diviser par quatre le contenu en gaz
carbonique de l'énergie dans un contexte
dans lequel je multiplie par deux
l'approvisionnement énergétique primaire
de la planète alors que deux par le
passé ce que j'ai réussi enfin ce que ma
confrérie a réussi à faire de mieux
c'est de gagner 10% sur 35 ans ce dans
quoi vous allez trouver la mise en
service des barrages la mise en service
des centrales nucléaires et les trois
trombones qui sont les panneaux
photovoltaïques et les éoliennes
donc il faut passer de 10% en 35 ans à
75% en 41 ans c'est à dire que
l'évolution qui était celle ci doit
devenir celle là alors la partie du bas
ch mans facile on en discutait ch m'en
fasse il suffit de monter les prix aucun
problème c'est le but du jeu de la taxe
carbone qui va être discutée dans quinze
jours ou trois semaines sous l'égide de
michel rocard est par contre ça alors là
accrochez vous accrochez vous parce que
si vous voulez faire ça sur les
renouvelables
voilà la situation de départ sur les
renouvelables alors les renouvelables
retenu une règle simple il y en a
d'autant moins sur la planète que le
journal français on parle plus assez
bonne approche assez bonne approximation
si vous voulez et non c'est ça de
manière plus rigoureuse c'est leur
importance dans le bilan énergétique
mondiale est inversement proportionnelle
à leur pagination au journal français si
vous demandez aux français ce que j'ai
vu dans un sondage dans les échos
excellent journal au demeurant n'est pas
très longtemps c'est quoi les énergies
renouvelables pour vous deux tiers des
français vous dise et les héros n'y
allez pas aux falaises et les panneaux
photovoltaïques banon ces énergies
renouvelables dans le monde c'est le
bois et ses l'hydroélectricité ce qui
veut dire soit dit en passant que les
pays dans lesquels vous avez beaucoup
d'énergie renouvelable
aujourd'hui c'est pas des pays dans
lesquels les dirigeants politiques sont
plus éclairés que les autres c'est des
pays dans lesquels la superficie
forestière et la superficie montagneuse
par tête de pipe sont plus élevés
qu'ailleurs
donc vous allez trouver beaucoup
d'énergies renouvelables dans les pays
nordiques
plein de forêt plein de montagne encore
un peu en suisse et en france pas mal de
montagne pas mal de forêt puis vous
allez au danemark
c'est tout plat et pas de forêt ils ont
beau mettre des lots à des éoliennes
partout
ça fait quelques % d'énergies
renouvelables dans le mix énergétique du
danemark
ça fait 13 % dans l'électricité parce
qu'ils en exporte une partie en circuit
fermé ça tiendrait pas aidé en reste ils
ont rien du tout que ça fait quelques
pourcents j'ai rien contre les danois
qui sont par ailleurs des gens charmants
je suis juste en train de rappeler que
les ordres de grandeur sont là et que
les ordres de grandeur c'est que les
deux énergies qui compte aujourd'hui
c'est le bois et l'hydroélectricité
alors je dis que je veux faire 4 % par
an en 50 ans alors j'ai pris 41 c'est
pas grave les ordres de grandeur reste
valable
ça va me faire 4 % par an alors question
est-ce que je peux mettre en culture
énergétique l'équivalent de la totalité
de la superficie forestière mondiale
sais pas si vous avez envie de postuler
comme chef de projet pour faire ça moi
poursuivants est ce que dans le même
temps vous pouvez multiplier par sept le
nombre de retenue sur terre bat quand
vous allez demander aux spécialistes de
l'hydroélectricité ils vous disent par 3
je veux bien par set j'ai du mal et le
barrage des trois gorges est ce que
c'est vachement écolo avoir un grand un
grand débarras est-ce qu'on va réussir à
faire passer les biocarburants de 30
millions de tonnes équivalent pétrole à
7000 ce qui correspond à une situation
dans laquelle vous doubler ou tripler le
parc de voitures dans le monde avec tout
le monde qui roule au biocarburant n'y
comptez pas une seconde il n'y aura pas
de biocarburants pour tout le monde
il y en aura même pour personne les
biocarburants il y en aura pour faire
les cultures et pour faire avancer les
avions de chasse ça je deviens le reste
rien il n'y aura rien c'est même pas la
peine d'y compter vous transforme huriez
aujourd'hui alors quand on se dit quand
j y aura rien c'est y aura rien à 9
milliards de bons jeunes voulant tous
rouler dans une voiture d'une tonne de
pois et dans les 30 ans qui viennent
je précise un peu ma mon affirmation mai
si on divise par dix préalablement le
parc de voitures dans le monde en
divisant également le poids de chaque
voiture par trois c'est même pas la
peine d'en parler des biocarburants
aujourd'hui vous convertir y est la
totalité de la production céréalière
mondiale en biocarburant que ça vous
ferait le quart du pétrole que
l'humanité consomme fort get it
est-ce que l'éolien qui fait aujourd'hui
20 millions de tonnes équivalent pétrole
dans un monde qui en consomment 12000 va
nous tirer d'affaires dans les 20 ou 30
ans qui rennes qui est qu'il vienne
pardon donc vous pouvez mettre tous les
milliards que vous voulez dans l'éolien
demain matin et monsieur borloo on peut
faire des grands sauts en disant que
c'est un truc génial ça ne changera
strictement rien à l'évolution du monde
et de nos misérable existence dans les
30 ans qui viennent
rien ça changera un peu l'avis des
fabricants d'éoliennes
ça changera un peu la vie tant qu'il y
en a des gens qui installent des
éoliennes dans leurs champs et qui
permettent à leur mère de toucher de la
taxe professionnelle jeudi temps qui en
a pas ce qu'il est question de la
supprimer la taxe maintenant quand vous
demandez aux élus locaux aussi pour deux
fois le montant de la taxe il prendrait
un abattoir à cochons plutôt qu'éolienne
ils vous disent tous oui en fait le test
donc donc le mais c'est donc ça ça me
gêne pas le donc le c'est juste pour
vous dire qu'aujourd'hui tout l'argent
qu'on met dans l'éolien ont fait bien
mieux le mettre il ya des tas d'autres
trucs qu'on ferait même on ferait mieux
de le mettre à commencer par financer
gratos de la capture et séquestration
chez les chinois je serait vachement
mieux à la fois pour les emplois
français est pour et pour votre avenir
climatique est bien et c'est pareil est
ce que le photovoltaïque qui aujourd'hui
est essentiellement une machine à capter
des subventions avec 15 % de taux de
rendement sur capitaux investis donc on
aurait vraiment tort de se priver est un
truc qui va sauver la planète que non
mettons quelques milliards dans la
recherche sur ça je suis tout à fait
pour pour franchir des sceaux qui sont
encore à franchir parce que tous les
gens qui travaillent là dedans le dise
ça sert à rien aujourd'hui de financer
du kilowattheure à 50 centimes le tarif
de rachat
on est en train de perdre notre temps et
comme le journal fait un papier là
dessus de bell qui fait un papier là
dessus ou un papier sur une centrale à
charbon ça accréditent l'idée
extrêmement délétère dans la population
dans son ensemble qu'on est en train de
répondre aux problèmes dans les bon
ordre de grandeur
or comme on est dans une course contre
la montre ça c'est quelque chose qui est
vraiment très grave mon oreille 50 ans
devant nous on s'en foutrait on verra
que ça marche pas faire autre chose sauf
que là on les a pas est-ce qu'on peut
recourir au nucléaire jeu imagine que
c'est un vrai sujet de débat chez vous
alors je vais vous donner mes
conclusions à moi ma conclusion à moi
c'est que la presse
dit des bêtises dans beaucoup de
domaines y compris les conséquences
sanitaires de ce truc là que les déchets
ça m'empêchera pas de dormir si c'est ça
le truc que je lègue à mes enfants je
suis un père heureux
la question des réserves et déjà un
point plus intéressant l'uranium 235 y
en a pas tant que ça
donc il faut passer à autre chose assez
rapidement si on veut faire du nucléaire
de manière significative
cela étant si vous voulez faire + 4 %
par an sur le nucléaire
là vous tombez sur des limites qui ne
sont pas des limites de dangerosité qui
sont ou de risque qui sont des limites
de disponibilité des capitaux des
compétences des emplacements des
sociétés solar donc je ne crois pas non
plus que le nucléaire va nous tirer
d'affaires de cette histoire ce que je
crois c'est que là où on en a et il
marche à peu près ça serait dommage de
s'en passer
je pense qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'endroits où on peut en rajouter plus
sans que ça m'empêche de dormir mais
l'idée que c'est juste ça qui va nous
tirer d'affaires est une idée à laquelle
je ne souscris pas alors maintenant je
vous propose une autre équation de kaya
on va un peu changer les termes voyez ça
on divise toujours par deux la
population on va considérer qu'on tue
personne pour le moment
donc elles augmentent toujours autant
faim du pib qui croient donc le pib est
à croissance nulle sauf que aujourd'hui
le pib mondial par personne et aux
alentours de 8000 $ par habitant et par
an est le vôtre et aux alentours de 30
mille dollars par habitant et par an
donc si j'égalise les conditions de vie
sur terre je divise vos revenus par cinq
d'accord vous direz vous expliquer avec
les autres c'est ça que je fais à ce
moment si je suis en prolongation
tendancielle sur l'efficacité
énergétique
je peux me contenter de juste 25% sur le
gain en co2 par unité d'énergie et ça je
veux bien d'accord ça physiquement pour
moi c'est un truc qui peut à calar
ailleurs tenir la route
mais vous voyez que ça veut dire que ce
terme là dans les pays industrialisés
actuelle il va faire quelque chose qui
est à 180 degrés de ce que les lecteurs
réclament aujourd'hui
alors comme je pense que toute façon
c'est ça qui va se passer pour partie je
fais partie des gens qui considèrent
qu'il est urgent d'abandonner cet
indicateur qui comme je vous l'aï dit au
début de mon exposé ne représente plus
rien et quand vous vous doter d'un
indicateur de progrès c'est pas pour
voir descendre un truc qui humainement
ne se gère pas c'est d'avoir un
indicateur de progrès qui descend ainsi
un indicateur de progrès pour vous ces
noms de papier publié que vous en aviez
50 l'année dernière et l'année prochaine
vous en aurez plus 45 parce qu on vous
en a retiré cinq ne pas considérer que
c'est
significatif enfin que c'est
représentatif d'une évolution qui vous
plaît donc si vous vous doter d'un
indicateur du progrès vous avez envie
qu'il croise comme celui là je pense
qu'il va arrêter de croître pour des
raisons physiques faut s'en débarrasser
le plus vite possible et c'est pas une
affaire d'idéologie c'est une affaire de
maintien de la stabilité sociale
c'est tout à fait différent parce que si
on n'arrive pas à régler le problème de
nous mêmes
il ya des tas de solutions qui peuvent
s'appliquer vous voyez si on n'arrive
pas si on a vraiment la contrainte là et
qu'on n'arrive pas à la voir là ou là
eh bien vous avez des tas de trucs qui
se chargeront très bien de réguler la
faire sur le pib par personne ou sur la
taille de la population voilà vous savez
on a énormément de solutions à notre
disposition pour ce genre de choses donc
la solution existera c'est juste que où
elle nous plaira ou elle ne plaira pas
ou plus exactement où ça sera un peu
d'effort ou ça on sera de manière
considérable et avant d'ouvrir les
questions quelques éléments juste sur le
rôle des médias dans cette démocratie
dans laquelle n'oublions pas ce que
l'essentiel des émetteurs et des
consommateurs d'énergie aujourd'hui
vivent dans des démocraties là tout ce
que je suis en train de vous cirque
laisser des démocraties dans le monde
ça c'est essentiellement des démocraties
dont vous avez la birmanie enfin me anne
marque il en n'est pas tellement une ici
vous en avait une qui est pas mais
l'essentiel des émissions mondiales se
passe en démocratie et en démocratie
vous avez quelques règles du jeu qu'il
est important de garder à l'esprit la
première c'est que les gens votent quel
que soit leur niveau de connaissances
préalables c'est normal ça fait partie
des règles du jeu
or quand vous regardez comment les gens
s'informent vous vous rendez compte que
le genre d'exercice auquel on est en
train de se livrer en ce moment concerne
une fraction minoritaire de l'électorat
ce que je suis en train de faire là si
je le fais une fois par semaine ce qui
est à peu près mon rythme ainsi je le
fais pendant 40 ans et vous avez compris
que c'est pas sûr que je vive aussi
vieux et que si on est à peu près 100
par conférence qui est la moyenne
voilà vous êtes un peu plus nombreux
mais il ya également des fois où les
gens le sont un peu moins et bien à la
fin de ma mon existence j'aurais touché
200 mille personnes
pour la france il y a à peu près 30
millions d'électeurs deux cent mille
personnes
or 0 5% mais pareil 0,3 pour cent de la
population
ridicule
après je pars dont je peux faire un
bouquin on vous a dit que je m'étais
essayé à l'exercice un certain nombre de
fois et là aussi je peux vous dire alors
c'est peut-être quelques dizaines de
milliers de lecteurs que je vais avoir
les derniers ont été vendus à 10 15
milles exemplaires si ils ont chacun
deux ou trois lecteurs mais y en a aussi
des gens je suis sûr que des gens qui
l'achètent et qui s'en sert pour calais
d'autres livres à ce moment mais c'est
très bien ça fait du stock de carbone
sur étagère à ce moment ça vous fait
vous voyez vous êtes un à deux ordres de
grandeur en dessous de du public qu'on
peut toucher en faisant ce genre
d'exercice et en plus évidemment vous
avez un recouvrement très fort entre les
deux après on peut faire un site
internet j'en ai fait un aussi on peut
avoir quelques milliers de visiteurs par
jour vous pouvez faire le calcul sur
l'année sauf que ça recouvre les deux
publics précédent et qu'en plus là
dedans c'est toujours les mêmes qui
reviennent une fois deux fois trois fois
25 fois dans l'année donc là on n'arrive
pas à décoller de la centaine de
milliers de personnes concernées si vous
voulez décollé de la centaine de
milliers de personnes concernées fois
l'étape et là dedans donc en gros vous
êtes obligé de faire confiance à un
relais qui s'appelle les journalistes et
qui vont permettre à cette information
qui est là et que vous détenez vous par
exemple sur la question du
fonctionnement de la machine climatique
à cette population qui vote et qui se
trouve là est encore toute la population
qui vote ne se trouve pas là puisqu'il
ya une partie des gens dans ce pays qui
ne lisent jamais le moindre journal et
quand ils vont sur internet c'est pour
regarder youtube
donc vous avez une partie des gens qui
votent et tout ce qu'ils ont comme
information c'est ce que leur a raconté
le voisin de la voisine du copain de
machines qui lui a vu quelque chose
c'est tout si vous avez joué au
téléphone arabe dans leur jeunesse vous
rappeler ce que ça donne comme résultat
alors le journal c'est quoi le journal
c'est la quadrature du cercle
puisque vous avez ici en gros le dilemme
dans lequel ils sont en permanence même
quand ils sont de bonne volonté et même
quand vous avez affaire à des gens
compétents
voilà ils sont tout le temps là dedans
alors pas de chance l'environnement
c'est que des trucs très compliqué on a
parlé là de physique et de mathématiques
est encore à mon niveau pour votre donc
il ya des tas de trucs qui sont
extrêmement compliquées et ils savent
pas traiter le compliqué et les
problèmes dont je viens de parler
heureusement vous pouviez pas sortir
sans être impoli parce que sinon vous
l'auriez fait donc c'est monstrueux mais
quand vous êtes seul derrière votre
écran de télévision vous ap sauf que les
médias ne doivent pas faire fuir ce qui
le ramène
leur pognon parce que l'audience d'un
media c'est son pognon c'est même son
pognon quand il s'agit d'une chaîne
publique parce que son audience
conditionne l'idée que le législateur se
fait du nombre de bonhomme qui doivent
travailler dedans donc le budget donc
c'est vous êtes tenus par ce genre de
choses alors pour vous montrer à quel
point c'est la quadrature du cercle j'ai
pris l'exemple du climat mais l'énergie
ce serait pareil
allez je prends le nombre de pages que
j'ai vu cité dans le dernier rapport du
giec
donc je dis j'ai une matière première
qui fait au moins 200 mais j'ai vérifié
qu'elle ait pas trop de recoupement donc
il y avait au moins deux cent mille
pages de matières primaires c'est-à-dire
de littérature scientifique et à mon
avis permet d'autre m'a dit qu'ils
pensaient que celle et rocket fois ça
vous allez en faire un tome du rapport
du giec c'est à dire 800 pages je peux
vous assurer que il n'ya pas un
journaliste dans ce pays qu'il a lu une
extension il n'y a pas un élu dans ce
pays qui la lui next un saut il n'y a
pas un responsable économique dans ce
pays qu'il a lu une extension pas un pas
un si vous me trouvez je vous paye trois
bouteilles de champagne mumm 30
oui sauf que là déjà on est passé de 200
mille pages à 800 c'est à dire que c'est
comme s'ils ont compris mais senteurs de
courant 24 minutes et leur résumé pour
décideurs revient à comprimer ça en 30
secondes
donc c'est un parfait par construction
peut pas faire autrement
donc tous les gens qui disent le résumé
pour décideurs ne reflète pas at elle
nuancé
évidemment nous les faire autrement si
vous voulez vous tapez les nuances et
ben vous engouffrez ça vous y passez
votre vie et quand vous allez passer à
un article dans le journal
vous allez passer à une demi page une
page dans les bons cas de figure c'est à
dire que vous aurez à résumer tout ça en
deux secondes
en gros c'est passé de 100 heures de
cours à 2 secondes imaginez que vous
soyez journalistes dans cette salle
quoi que vous ayez pensé de ce que je
vous ai raconté la commande de vote
rédac'chef c'est d'en faire un quart de
page d'un journal vous allez mettre quoi
vous allez mettre quoi je pourrais faire
l'exercice ne vous demander de rédiger
un quart de page ramasse les copies à la
fin je regarde ce que c'est évident que
vous êtes dans une situation impossible
c'est impossible totalement impossible
alors là je suis un peu caricatural de
temps en temps vous avez des émissions
de plateau
on est plus sur une demi page dans le
journal on est sur un quart d'heure
enfin encore une fois 100 heures de
cours en un quart d'heure ça reste un
truc qui a
impressionnant après vous avez également
un problème de sélection de
l'information
alors là aussi je me livrer à un petit
quizz qui a déjà lu dans le journal un
article disant du mal des juges
juste trois un article qu'ils ont déjà
du mal qui a déjà lu un article ils ont
du mal des juges dans le journal je dis
pas de tous qui a lu dans le journal un
article disant du mal du fonctionnement
du monde politique qui a lu dans le
journal un article disant du mal sur la
conscience professionnelle des
chercheurs qui a déjà lu dans le journal
un article vous expliquant les vices de
fonctionnement structurel de la presse 5
et je suis sûr ce n'était ni dans
libération ni dans le monde ni au 20
heures de tf1
donc en gros pour l'essentiel des gens
qui s'informent vous ne savez pas
comment l'information arrive à vous vous
ne le savez pas vous ne savez absolument
pas pourquoi le rédac chef a décidé de
couvrir ceux ci plutôt que cela alors
moi je le sais c'est parce que les
communiqués de presse qui sont arrivés
ce matin parlait d'un nombre restreint
de sujet et qu'il a pioché dedans et pas
dans le reste quand vous rentrez pour
ceux d'entre vous qui ont déjà eu à
faire dans une rédaction de radio
le premier truc que vous trouvez à
gauche en entrant sur le bureau c'est
une pile épaisse comme ça des quotidiens
du jour etc etc
donc en gros c'est un truc qui tourne en
circuit fermé et la sélection des
informations n'est en rien liée à
l'importance réelle des phénomènes dans
le monde
vous savez pas pourquoi on est allé
interroger machin plutôt que truc alors
ça aussi moi je le sais parce que machin
était disponible et pas truc ou parce
que machin était déjà dans le carnet
d'adressés du journaliste et patrick ou
parce que et c'est ça veut pas dire que
machin soit mauvais ça veut juste dire
que le processus de sélection n'est pas
nécessairement lié à la compétence alors
avec le temps quand le journaliste
connaît bien son sujet et c'est ça
devient beaucoup moins vrai et encore et
encore vous avez des journalistes qu'on
leur tête ils gardent leur tête vous ne
savez pas non plus si la personne qui a
causé pendant trois quarts d'heure ce
qui va être restituée de ces propos
c'est quelque chose qui ressemble à ce
qu'elle a dit ou si c'est totalement
différent ne le savez pas la majeure
partie du temps le journaliste fait
honnêtement son travail donc il veut
vraiment restituer mais temps en temps
c'est un sujet n'offrent donc il
restitue de travers
et de temps en temps ils à mettre dans
le nez pour dieu sait quelle raison il
cherche à lui faire dire des trucs que
l'on n'a pas envie de dire
et à ce moment il vous fait dire des
trucs que vous ne pensez pas vous ne
savez pas si vous avez c'est évident que
les journalistes en ont tous on en a
tous
quand on cause vingt minutes devant une
caméra et qu' il en passe quinze
secondes au jt vous savez pas pourquoi
on va sélectionner ceux ci plutôt que
cela et quand vous êtes interviewé dans
le journal vous ne savez pas si la
personne interviewée a pu relire ses
propos et valider ce qu'on lui fait dire
ou pas sachant qu'en plus le premier jet
n'ai jamais fait par la personne
interviewée s'est fait par la personne
dont le nom suis propos recueillis par
et cette personne envoie un draft et
vous avez très exactement une heure et
demie pour le relire et corriger quand
c'est un quotidien donc c'est évident
que vous rédigez pas tout même si c'est
un style qui vous ressemblent pas et
c'est évident que vous repêché que les
plus grosses conneries et en plus
comment vous explique qu'il faut pas à
reprendre un caractère de plus parce que
sinon c'est de nouveau le même processus
à la région vous êtes ça donc voilà donc
ce que je suis en train de vous dire
c'est que l'information qui parvient au
grand public par vient au terme d'un
processus qui danse allez on va dire
dans bon nombre des cas fonctionne à peu
près correctement sauf que le grand
public ne sait pas faire la distinction
entre ce qui a bien fonctionné et ce qui
a mal fonctionné en gros lui ne sait pas
quand est ce que le processus a bien
marché et quand est-ce qu'il a bien
marché et a mal marché
et enfin je vous disais tout à l'heure
le fait de pas faire fuir le public est
un truc important parce que le public
conditionne les recettes publicitaires
pour ceux qui en ont et les ventes au
numéro pour ceux qui en ont donc le
dernier truc dont vous avez envie dans
un canard c'est faire fuir vos lecteurs
et ça ça vous explique un certain nombre
d'autres choses donc par exemple le fait
que allègre continue à avoir des micros
qui sont tendus vers lui parce que la
polémique est un truc qui fait vendre
discuter avec n'importe quel rédac'chef
il vous le dira donc ce qui fait
l'audience médiatique d'allègre n'est
pas la question du fond c'est la
question de la forme
s'ils avaient parallèlement il y aura
quelqu'un d'autre pour occuper sa place
pas à cause allègre à cause de la
manière dont le système fonctionne voilà
j'ai comme d'habitude menti dans les
grandes largeurs j'ai largement dépassé
mon temps mais vous aurez compris que le
débat qui est posée à travers la
contrainte carbone est de savoir si avec
l'évolution qu'on a suivi maintenant on
va faire ça ce que les femmes dans la
salle diront que les hommes font tous
les jours à partir de 19h
aussi on va faire ça c'est à dire rester
là où on est arrivés parce que le génie
humain arrivera à préserver un niveau de
confort matériel qui est qui ressemble
beaucoup à celui que nous avons
aujourd'hui et vous comprenez donc que
quand on parle de la contrainte carbone
on n'est pas en train de parler d'un
truc anecdotique
en tout cas c'était mon ambition c'était
juste de vous faire comprendre qu'on
n'est pas en train de parler d'un truc
anecdotique qu'on peut déléguer à
quelqu'un dans un coin en lui disant de
s'en occuper pendant que les autres s'en
occupe pas c'est pas vrai c'est un truc
qui nous concernera tous et qui va même
piloté de manière extrêmement
structurantes
les quelques dizaines d'années qui vont
commencer à partir de maintenant comme
ça à piloter de manière extrêmement
structurantes ce qui s'est passé sur le
dernier siècle et demi voilà je suis
désolé de vous avoir retenu pour l'heure
du repas et je vous remercie